this is jocko podcast number 291 with
echo charles and me
jaco willink good evening echo
your responsibilities may involve the
command of more traditional forces but
in less traditional roles
men risking their lives not as
combatants but as instructors or
advisors
or as symbols of our nation's
commitments
the fact that the united states is not
directly at war in these areas in no way
diminishes the skill and the courage
that will be required
the service to our country which is
rendered
or the pain of the casualties which are
suffered
to cite one final example of the range
of responsibilities that will fall upon
you
you may hold a position of command with
our special forces
forces which are too unconventional to
be called conventional
forces which are growing in number and
importance and significance
for we now know that it is wholly
misleading to call this the nuclear age
or to say that our security rests only
on the doctrine
of massive retaliation
korea has not been the only battleground
since the end of the second world war
men have fought and died in
malaya greece the philippines algeria
and cuba and cyprus and almost
continuously
on the indo-chinese peninsula
no nuclear weapons have been fired no
massive nuclear retaliation has been
considered appropriate
this is another type of war new in its
intensity
ancient in its origin war by guerrillas
subversives insurgents assassins
were by ambush instead of by combat
by infiltration instead of aggression
seeking victory by eroding and
exhausting the enemy
instead of engaging him
it is a form of warfare uniquely adapted
to what we to what has strangely been
called
wars of liberation to undermine the
efforts of new and poor countries to
maintain the freedom
that they have finally achieved
it preys on economic unrest and ethnic
conflicts
it requires in those situations where we
must counter it
and these are the kinds of challenges
that will be before us in the next
decade
if freedom is to be saved a whole new
kind of strategy
a wholly different kind of force and
therefore
a new and wholly different kind of
military training
and that right there was an excerpt from
a speech
by john f kennedy to the 1962
graduating class of west point the
united states military academy and that
same year he also released a message to
the u.s army
and that message read
to the united states army another
military dimension
guerrilla warfare has necessarily been
added to the
american profession of arms
the literal translation of guerrilla
warfare
a little war is hardly applicable to
this ancient
but at the same time modern threat
i note that the army has several terms
which describe the various facets of the
current struggle wars of subversion
covert aggression and in broad
professional terms
special warfare or unconventional
warfare
by whatever name this militant challenge
to freedom
calls for an improvement and enlargement
of our own development
of techniques and tactics communications
and logistics
to meet this threat the mission of our
armed forces
and especially the army today is to
master these skills
and techniques and to be able to help
those who have the will to help
themselves
pure military skill is not enough
a full spectrum of military paramilitary
and civil action
must be blended to produce success
the enemy uses economic and political
warfare propaganda and naked military
aggression
in an endless combination to oppose a
free choice of government
and suppress the rights of the
individual by terror
by subversion and by force of arms
to win in this struggle our officers and
men
must understand and combine and combine
the political
economic and civil actions with skilled
military efforts
in the execution of this mission the
green beret
is again becoming a symbol of excellence
a badge of courage
a mark of distinction in the fight for
freedom
i know the united states army will live
up to its reputation
for imagination resourcefulness
and spirit as we meet this challenge
signed john f kennedy
so the green berets the u.s
army special forces were formed for this
new type of warfare
well i guess as jfk said new in its
intensity but ancient
in its origin and today
almost 60 years since jfk made these
statements
there's a new generation of soldiers
that have trained incessantly to fight
this new type of warfare
and we're honored to have one of those
soldiers here tonight
with us to share some of his experiences
he served in us army special forces
worked as a contractor for some
government agencies
and has continued to hone his skills and
teach others
through his company field craft survival
his name is mike glover mike
thanks for coming out man thanks for
having me on it's an honor
happy to be here green berets green
berets
the deal we're kind of a big deal i
don't know if you knew that
yeah you know um obviously uh
the seal community gets quite a bit of
um
you know flak because we're like uh
i guess for lack of a better word kind
of popular right now yes but
people seem to forget there was the
green green beret movie way before
and and then i was thinking about the
actual delta force movie the other day
which was
way before anybody knew anything about
the seal team so
so anyways let's get to it man let's go
back to the beginning let's go back to
where
how you grew up where you're from what
turned you into you
oh conception in korea actually
conceived in korea conceived in korea my
dad was a joe
and an army kid what do you do so he had
two mls's he was a
95 bravo which is a military police
officer and a filled artillery guy what
years was he in
70 late 70s into the mid 80s
okay his his stint was was he did he go
to nam
he didn't he was he gre he was in high
school during vietnam
and then by time he got out the war had
been
fought it was over but
he got stationed in korea at some point
yeah i got stationed in korea
and met my beautiful mother at a very
young age
she was 18 years old and then they had
me at 19.
um wait how old was he 25
24 and um just
living his best life doing the army
thing
uh we actually moved to california to
fort ord california where i was born
in monterey it looks like a zombie
apocalypse there now the
actual base for looks like a sim shoot
house did it get shut down
it did they they shut down all the
buildings condemned them
but it's still open like you could drive
through it publicly so there's no gates
and um stationed in germany for a period
of time with my dad
as a young child and then
um parents separated so got to come to
daytona beach florida where i was
basically raised
going with who who'd you go with i went
with dad um
mom didn't speak any english uh met a
guy in germany
winded up getting back over to the us
where
um i i spent time between florida and
north carolina
splitting the difference growing up were
you
were you looking at the army like good
deal were you around the army all the
time
when you're when you're a little bit
older yeah it's like it's like us you
know we live
you know these civilian lives now but
there's always this
um evidence that we served in some
capacity so i saw that evidence as a
child
my dad had you know the dog tags the
pictures
the military gear i remember playing
with his ta-50 his old
military gear his his mess kit and all
of his
uh lbe and all the old stuff that we had
the webbing
and i just kind of knew growing up in
that environment that i was going to be
in the military
his brother was a career navy guy
so i was you know growing up with
charlie sheen
and navy sills and um chuck norris and
delta force and kind of
immersed in that and decided at a very
young age i mean
man as as as young as i can remember
that's all i wanted to do was do the
military
yeah that's the same with me i always
say people like when did you make that
decision i'm like
i don't know because i just remember
wanting
to wear camouflage uniforms as a little
kid yeah
that's what i remember well but you were
in mostly growing up in daytona beach
yeah daytona beach and then splitting
the difference between uh north carolina
my
my mom actually settled right outside of
fort bragg north carolina which i would
spend a lot of time what year were you
born
80. so you're growing up so now this is
like the 90s
yeah yeah it's weird i'm sitting here
talking to you and for some reason in my
mind i'm thinking i'm talking to like
what
like uh an older person yeah and i'm
thinking in my mind like oh it was the
50s
i don't know why i'm thinking that
because jfk yeah i guess
yeah i just read jfk so i'm thinking oh
yeah this is the 50s and then i started
thinking to myself wait a second
this is like i was already in the navy
when you're a freaking teenager
or whatever so you're growing up in the
90s 90s what year did you go in the navy
1990 90 okay i was 10. yeah that was 10.
wow wow
now i feel young all of a sudden yeah
yeah so so
what are you doing in daytona beach
what's the scene down there
are you in the water are you surfing are
you listening to music what are you
listening to no i was i mean my dad
jokes and and says that i was a part
fish because i was always in the water
i mean i remember training i wanted to
be a navy seal when i first started
thinking about the military my uncle was
very pro navy obviously my dad was pro
army and i remember jumping and diving
in the pools and doing
underwater udt challenges like tying
knots
you know there was no discovery channel
or there was no
representation mainstream of what navy
seals did it was udt
it was charlie sheen and navy seals so i
wanted to do that but i grew up in the
water
outdoor fishing i grew up on a boat i
mean i think i was out
we probably fish four days a week what
was your dad's civilian job
so he he immediately transferred from
the military and worked for the
department of corrections for the state
of florida so he started doing
corrections at an early age
right out of the military which
transitioned his retirement benefits a
whole bunch of cool stuff for him
and that's all i remember him doing and
then are you uh
is he liv does he is there another like
did he get remarried or something who's
taking care of you when he's at work
yeah i mean
man if i could reflect on that time
period
i think i did a lot of taking care of
myself but i was super independent i was
an only child
so it was just me you know so growing up
um i had a good imagination it was very
responsible as a kid
i don't remember getting in trouble i
wasn't into bars wasn't into
weed all the typical things that kids
are into i remember
like doing con up i concept of the
operation plans in breeze
as a 10 year old i had a toy mp5 and
planting ops
getting guccied out and geared up and
then doing these like
low vis operations at night and then
even a or i didn't even know what an aar
was an after action review
i would come back and like let's talk
about it like weird stuff who's we
like all my friends oh okay yeah yeah i
was just that kid
yeah i was that kid hey did you what
about the the fact that your parents got
divorced did you did you have
like uh animosity towards your dad or
towards your mom or were you just
did you just kind of because you know
when when divorce happens at a young age
sometimes kids can't understand it and
it it makes them
you know uh uh i guess have some kind of
animosity towards one parent or the
other
sounds like you were pretty maybe you
kind of uh because you can also when you
get older you go yeah you know what they
just you know they did this when they
were a little too young or they didn't
get along they weren't quite a good fit
and i get it and we're going to carry on
yeah that was me man i just never had a
i never developed animosity for any of
my parents based on
the things they weren't potentially
doing right i i don't know if it was
because i was taught not to judge people
and even my family in the circumstance i
was in what i looked at
it was a very adaptive opportunity for
me to
to go to different places meet different
family members and then have these cool
experiences i mean i grew up in north
carolina with my cousins
um running the streets doing playing war
shooting bb guns and then i come back to
florida then i was hanging out with my
dad
fishing outdoors on the beach in the
water and so i
i had a really good childhood i despite
the problem that was separation
which eventually at the age of 12 winded
up moving back to my mom's
taking advantage of opportunities there
what was the what were the opportunities
there
so um when i went so my obviously my mom
and dad are in kind of like cahoots in
competition with each other
because they want to have me you know
and so i'm going back and forth getting
spoiled and
in separate ways but i remember actually
on the summer of like when i was 12 or
my mom tried to convince me that hey you
know your dad just met a new woman which
she did which was going to be my stepmom
she had three kids at the time and then
it's an allocation of resources right
when you have
three new children in the home you don't
get taken care of like you used to
and so i was like yeah maybe i want to
give my mom a chance
and live with my mom and it's a good
situation so i just said dad i'm just
gonna live with my mom
and he was i remember painfully
he was bummed out i don't think i've
ever heard my dad my dad cry or saw him
cry
and i think he was crying on the phone
when i told him that and
it created a divide because i was his
only baby boy
but um he had children to take care of
he had a newborn with
the woman that he was with and i knew he
had this life yet this vertical he had
to concentrate on
so i lived with my mom and then you know
in north carolina and
uh and she wasn't she wasn't wealthy at
all she was an entrepreneur
small business beauty salon we were
struggling i thought it was going to be
like oh this is cool because my mom buys
me crap
all the time my dad never buys me stuff
and so i went into that opportunity
and realized hey i mean me and my mom
are gonna have to fend for ourselves
was she with another guy at this point
she was she was with my stepdad she
eventually met my stepdad at 15. she had
a boyfriend at the time
named alex was a good dude from that she
had met in germany had brought her over
um but she was trying to find her way i
mean i mean i don't even think
and this is this is uh uh honest
reflection i don't think i had shoes
until i was like 14. like i had
flip-flops
it was like she didn't have a car until
i was 15 um because she couldn't afford
a car
so we didn't have a lot of things that
were basics because she was grinding as
an entrepreneur
but that taught me more about life
moving forward
being adaptive and eventually becoming a
military leader
i think a lot of those experiences come
from that
you know he said you said first of all
it's pretty amazing how you were
kind of detached and able to not be
emotional about these decisions and
stuff as a
kid you also said hey uh i was taught
not to judge people
who taught you that i grew up as a
baptist and um
i wasn't like i'm not a super religious
person i never have been but i've
questioned
i remember crying as a kid when i was in
my bed
trying to think about what the next step
was for people
like what happens when you die i
remember i actually i remember this
thought because
it stuck with me i said to myself in my
head i said wait a minute
if if uh god's jesus is father
then who's god's father and there's this
void in my brain i'm like
oh my god i can't figure this out and i
remember being distraught and so
religion kind of brought that together
for me so i grew up like a christian
non-denominational
and was taught a lot of values that way
also my dad's a military-minded guy
so discipline integrity honor all those
things were instilled at me at a young
age too
and then what at what point did you
because you were in the water all the
time
and it seems like that would be a good
call to go in the navy
and and try and go in the seal teams
what made you make the decision to
go in the army instead yeah good
question i i never been asked that but
specifically i know the exact moment
um i was on my the steps of my grandma's
house
in daytona beach and my uncle who was
still
active navy had just come back from um
being on the water
and in the fleet and i was talking to
him about being a navy seal
and he said listen i know you're torn
between the two do you want me a green
beret do you want to be a navy seal
and for a kid it's like it's a choice
but you don't realize the
the progress that you have to go through
and so i'm like
so what happens if i fail i said if i go
to selection
and all right go to buds if i fail what
happens he goes
you're mopping a deck forever he goes
and then he told me about the whole
recruit me
he actually tried out for buds and
didn't make it when he was young in the
navy
and he said hey there's a whole bunch of
guys i served with that didn't make it
that fill all the slots in the navy that
nobody else wants to do and i'm like
so what happens if i'm in the army and
then my dad was there to educate me says
listen
you could be an airborne ranger you pass
ranger school
you go to selection you don't make it
you're still an airborne ranger
combat arms and i'm like well i just
want to be in the fight and i
made the decision right there in that
moment was like okay let me see the path
that leads me to be a special forces guy
when i was 10 years old i made a bet
with my dad that i was going to be a
green beret damn betterman
bet him an mp5sd did he pay up no i had
to buy it myself
i had to buy myself he could buy me a
phoenix arms 22 right now
the uh the fact that what what the fact
that you were able to calculate that
is incredible when i i was freaking
you know i was like i think i was 18
when i joined
but i might have been 17 on the maps
program anyways i was young
but i was older than you were at age 10
yeah and i didn't even
figure out that hey that that thing
never came into my
mind what if you don't make it yeah
which is a stupid thing to be thinking
because there's
80 attrition rate in buds and it's
totally uh it's it's the worst
i mean look here here's what's the worst
if you join the navy because you want to
be
a mechanic or you want to be an uh work
on
aviation equipment that's awesome the
navy is freaking a great place to get
those kind of jobs that are
sort of like industrial blue-collar jobs
the navy is freaking awesome for that
you you want to like i said you want to
be a diesel mechanic bro go
go join the navy you'll get awesome
experience of that you want to learn
about
communication systems technical stuff
the navy's great
but the type of person that wants to be
a seal doesn't want to do those kind of
things yes
at all at least as far as i can tell so
but that's what you're going to end up
as and so it's really a bad deal
if you don't make it it's not not going
to be fun what's worse too you train
up for that job before you get used to
right you used to train up for that job
yeah so then what's a good thing is you
see
how much that job potentially sucks yeah
so when you go into buzz that's your
motivation i don't want to go back to
that thing that vocational thing no it's
it's great and the other thing that's
that's really good about the army and
the marine corps is you get all this
fundamental basic infantry small unit
training
before you go to special operations
training so
in the in the seal teams
you don't have that you don't have this
sort of base of knowledge of
fundamental small unit tactics like you
have in the army and the marine corps
so how old are you when you and lest 17
yeah i joined when i was 17.
and go to boot camp got what you
expected
yeah i went to infantry boot camp when
the sand hill became a
11 bravo i actually signed up to be a an
airborne ranger
an option 40 contract which is known as
the the option to go to ranger battalion
oh so that's that means you're going to
a battalion
yeah i was i was so i was set to go to
battalion but what i signed up for as an
mos was called 11
x-ray and 11 x-ray is similar to the 18
x-ray where
the x stands for they fill the gap they
decide what they
want to make you so back in the day it's
not like this now but back in the day
there was
four different specialties in the
infantry 11 bravo charlie delta
and mike and uh or not mike not delta
but mike
and hotel so if you are 11 bravo
infantrymen if you're a charlie
morterman
if you're a mike mc heavyweight um
mechanized vehicles if you're a hotel
heavy armor
like riding on humvees so basically an
infantryman with different skill sets
well when i got there the way they
selected us
and grouped us was based on where we
were standing so they said hey you guys
in a
group you're going to be bravo's like
literally standing
literally where you're standing in your
class rank or anything like that just
where you're standing where you were
lumped
together and so they're like you lump
you're going to be a bravo
you know and they made the mosses well
they made me an uh 11 hotel
and so i'm like okay so i'm an infantry
guy that drives and humvee shoots 50
cals and tow missiles cool let's do this
at the end of basic training where they
transition you
and they go to ait where you get your
advanced training
um they they're supposed to have a rip
brief a ranger indoctrination
program brief so the rip instructor
comes
and i'm like what's going on here like
he's not talking to us he's talking to
the bravos and the charlie's
like why isn't he talking to us don't
even think anything about it because i'm
like
i'm a e1 i don't have a rank right and
so
no no foot to stand on so we go through
the training and at the end
they go hey mike you're going to fort
lewis washington to um
an infantry unit and i'm like i i have a
ranger contract airborne ranger contract
so they look at my mls and go no you're
a hotel ranger battalion doesn't have
hotels
i'm like what like what do you mean they
don't have hotels
like you should have told us before you
went to ait i'm like i'm a private i
think i tried to say something but you
guys ignored me so
luckily for me my uncle was a sergeant
major
in the 18th airborne corps big division
of uh
airborne infantry units so i call him
during my little break
and like this is what happened so he
gets this
you know long story short he gets this
connection where this
old guard recruiter comes in and i'm in
a room like similar to this
and they're like i know your uncle i'm
gonna hook you up like literally the guy
says it to me is the e5
and he's the recruiter for the old guard
the third infantry regiment
right i don't even know what the hell
the old guard is i'm like okay
what do i got to do and a civilian comes
in and he looks at my orders he says
give me your orders and he looks at it
and my mos says 11 hotel
he literally takes a pin and scratches
that 11 hotel
writes 11 bravo and then signs his
initials boom
and it instant 11 bravo and i'm like
oh and i'm like okay so am i going to
battalion he goes well first
we can't do that we have to send you to
the old guard because that's part of
this deal
when we send you the old guard because
uh you're
you could only be 11 bravo going the old
guard we're gonna send you there
and then you could put a 4187 everybody
back in the day even
kinda now says yeah 4187 is the way that
you migrate and do whatever you want to
do
not true so i get the old guard no idea
what the old guard is
and long story short they're their
ceremonial unit of the u.s military
they do all the full honor funerals the
state dignitary escorts
all the stuff i did not want to do um
i had to take advantage of my time this
is pre g-wat
so i'm like so we're talking what like
uh 97
97 97. so i get there and
i you know luckily for my um
circumstance
my uncle is very well known in these
units he he served as a platoon sergeant
does her storm
uh he's just a popular character in the
infantry in this in these particular
units
and the old guard for infantry guys is
like a break yeah you go to korea
you go to the 82nd and then you go to
the old girl to take a break
so i get there e1 don't know anything
and i realize it's not the place that i
want to be
but i have to take advantage of my time
so i head on a trajectory
to focus on setting myself up for
success
to be the best version of special forces
um that i could be and so that's that's
where that journey began
did any was anyone telling you what to
do was anyone talking to you about it
was anyone telling you about selection
or what you need to get ready for or
anything like that were you reading
about it
so i was so books or have been a big
part of my life since
the origins of where i wanted to be in
the military
you know the marcenko books the you know
the
the marine sniper all these books john
plaster mack visage
john striker's stories all these stories
i was
digesting and absorbing i even stole in
basic training a book called commandos
that was a paperback book from the drill
sergeant's
pool table haul while i was doing kp
where i was cleaning crap
up and because i was like i i want to
digest this i was like hiding doing that
stuff
and so i had an understanding of what it
took
in in discipline but i had no idea
because i didn't get any intel
as i got into the infantry i
i maximized my time i trained up for
ranger school i went to ranger school as
an 18 year old pfc a private first class
i went to airborne school how hard is it
to get a billet to rangers goal as an 18
year old
almost impossible so there's a
there's tryouts most infantry units run
what's called pre-arranger
and and people think hey you raise your
hand you get a slot that's not true
for battalion it's a requirement so they
get the majority of the slots
if you're a regular infantry unit you
get slots based on
order of merit so they have an oml list
and
if you earn it they'll give you a slot
and then you're on the list and then you
just trickle your way to the top
so i tried out for it about 30 of us
tried out for us only three of us got
slots
and i was a young pfc what's the trial
based on
freaking pt test and weapons assembly or
something well it's harder than ranger
school
so it's it's about a week right so in a
week it's like
how much crap can we put together in a
week to crush these kids
to see who's most likely to succeed
because these units have their
reputation on the line
if the third inventory regiment sends
five dudes to raider school and nobody
passes
it reflects poorly on on the regiment so
when i showed up
um it was a rucksack it was a
you know a ruck march 12 miles in time
it was land navigation it was a common
core task it was patrolling
the number one thing that's going to
make you successful isn't your physical
fitness and around your school
it's your ability to lead and so as a
young 18 year old at the time
i'm navigating this problem set it's
like hey pfc glover give a warno give a
con
up and i'm like oh like i have to brief
this
so planning and then executing that raid
was a reflection of your probability of
success in ranger school
so i was successful yeah and you're a
pfc and there's 30 people try out and
you get selected
i got selected yeah i was one of one of
three that got selected
we went to ranger school i was actually
the only one out of the three that went
all the way through without recycling
and
in my infantry company the only people
ranger qualified was me as a pfc
and my first sergeant who was a senior
uh
e8 in the army so it was back then it
was rare it was rare to have a ranger
tab
on your uniform how was ranger school
kicking the balls kicking the balls um
fear was the um
the thing that i had to overcome was the
most difficult thing that i had to
overcome
i remember like the night before ranger
school fear i'm assuming fear of failure
fear of failure absolutely and um
you know you have no perspective you
just have these stories
you know my squad leader had been to
ranger school before so he was feeding
me information which almost makes it
worse right
like you gotta you gotta be aware of
this and and you're trying to live
with that solution in mind and you're
getting hit with all these other random
jabs in the face
i showed up and i'm super physically fit
and i remember getting my um
i had a low body fat high physical
fitness score
and when i got there i realized very
quickly
it wasn't about that it was a that's a
the ranger assessment part of ranger
school
is relatively easy i mean it's we're
talking eight minute mile pace
five miles 40 minutes we're talking
about basic
push-up sit-ups and running and pull-ups
and basic stuff
really quickly you start deteriorating
because you're not eating
you're averaging about one mre a day
when i went during winter time
and you're averaging about three and a
half hours of sleep those
difficulties for a dude i mean i went to
raynor school as even as an 18 year old
at 200 pounds
all the guys that were meatheads that
were big dudes
suffered the most because you need
protein to feed muscle
and when you're not getting that your
body starts deteriorating and
it's painful how much weight did you
lose 30 pounds
30 pounds yeah that's uh
that's good times yeah that's another
thing man
i might have taken the gamble you know
they're like hey listen jocko you might
end up on a ship somewhere but
if you go to ranger school guaranteed
you're not eating i'd have been like hmm
let me think about that one
yeah roll the dice yeah that's another
ball game that's the thing about buds
the thing about buds you're getting
fed man yeah and it's all you can eat
that's huge
it's beautiful they just want you jacked
that's huge but the thing is ranger
school
like you said ranger school is really
the premier leadership
school for the army it is yeah
absolutely you're running operations
you're um you're you're filling a
different role basically every operation
sometimes you're the leader sometimes
you're a freaking
machine gunner yep yeah yeah it's uh
you know when i went to raider school as
a very young kid
um i didn't know what to expect and then
it's sink or swim
you either step up to the plate and
you're prepared to be
look there's the characteristics of
being successful in range school aren't
that difficult
but being a clear concise decisive
leader
um under stress is super important and i
so and and for
for com you know comparably to all my
peers
which weren't peers i'm talking about
second lieutenants
that just graduated i obc infantry
officer basic course navy seals
green berets like these are guys that i
highly respect
so it was a whole plethora like a
melting pot of a whole bunch of
different backgrounds
and i realized when you took away food
when you took away sleep
when you broke everybody down we were on
this equal plane
and so the very minimal characteristics
that you needed to be successful and to
shine
were not that difficult and so i saw
people
uh sink and i saw people succeed because
they swam
those people that sunk were just they
couldn't make decisions
and then when they got stressed which
they'd never been tested in stress
they couldn't do basic basic skill sets
right so ranger school they give you the
formula
and here's the con up here's the five
paragraph op order here's how you
execute a rate
just follow that step by step and you'll
be successful
and i realized how analytic that was and
so i just needed to get through and
check the block and get it done
and i saw a lot of people um sink that i
highly respected
because they started falling apart i
mean i saw guys who were beef
um beefy dudes were jacked who were
strong
and they were getting broken down the
most because they couldn't handle the
deprivation of sleep and food
and when when i saw that as a young man
as a young leader
it changed my entire perspective on life
like it re-prioritized the hierarchy of
things that i thought were important
and i'm like that's not important like i
had like eating
eating and sleeping in the field to be
able to conduct an operation
are now the new priorities for me taking
care of my guys
so i came out of that as a very young
leader who wasn't even a i was an
informal leader i wasn't even a
designated leader
and that shaped me to become the leader
that i would become when you say people
that
would have trouble with people that were
having a hard time making a decision
like what
would they be having a hard time making
a decision like hey there's uh
where are we going to put this overwatch
position or where are we going to set up
the
the base element like those kind of
decisions yeah everything from technical
to
very cognitive decisions that had to be
made in
adapting to change rapidly so in ranger
school you get a set
mission which is based off your con up
that you plan it's a deliberate mission
set
contingency-based mission set you go in
the field with that and then after that
it's all fragos it's fragmentation
orders of
the mission's changing we're doing this
and mostly it had to do with the
adaptability of
adapting to rapid change hey guys this
just happened
now you have to dab what are you going
to do i have no idea it was probably a
lack of glucose in the brain
it was a lack of sleep i mean i had guys
that
broke down and like just quit because
when you get to that state
where you can't function mentally what's
going to get you through that
and typically it's grit it's resolved
it's it's digging deep
and some of those guys never found that
and even though they
they were tested and they had an
opportunity they never found it so when
we came out of the field
the greatest thing about rainer school
is you're judged by your peers
you you write down on a piece of paper
right at the v
like the second you come out of the
field you're smoked out of your mind
they put you in a classroom
they sit you down with a piece of paper
and they say write down
a person you want to go to war with and
write down a person you leave behind
and that's that's super impactful for a
young man
being told that they would be left
behind
by the majority of their peers that's
i mean it's super impactful because it's
like hey man adapt
change do some self reflection or
fail and just be that guy for the rest
of your life that
that right there set the precedence for
everything moving forward
and in ranger school one of the ways
that you could drop this by getting
peered out right where they
you get if you get ranked the lowest guy
x number of times
then the instructors are like yeah this
guy is not the guy that we want if you
get peered
and it's becoming a routine out of the
field you'll immediately get recycled
so a recycle isn't just like going back
to the beginning of that phase
it's potentially going back to the
beginning of rainer school
so now you're talking about when i was
doing school 70 plus days it was a
couple months
three different phases when i went darby
which is in the uh fort benning and sand
hill
dahlonega which is in the mountains and
then at eglin which is in the swamps
so if you get recycled you potentially
will go back to the phase
or go back to the very beginning i mean
i i uh
i interviewed a woman lisa jaster who
was one of the first females to go
through rainer school
she failed every phase she got to the
last
phase and failed and they said you
failed
so here's your options you could knock
down like it was a weird thing like
knock out these push-ups because we
gotta assess if you're physically
a fit to go ahead and go forward if you
don't knock them out and you can't meet
that standard
right now you're done but we're gonna
recycle you to the very
beginning so she was in right school for
like a year
like sustained combat operations and
sleep in food deprived for like a year
and i can't imagine but that was your
options it's either
again it's either sink or swim you have
an opportunity to succeed and change
the way you look at yourself which i
think is the most impactful that they
give you that opportunity
or continue to be that guy and then just
get [ __ ] camped
when are they helping people out by
let's say you get graded low
is an instructor going to come over to
you and say like hey listen here's
what's going on
you're really indecisive you need to
start thinking through these things the
reason i'm asking you this is because
like in basic seal training
first of all you're not doing anything
really tactical but second of all
there's no real hey bro here's the
mistake that you're making
whereas the kind of training that i ran
which was which is like the advanced
training like the
the the training that we do with
platoons before the
deployment right i mean that's all i'm
doing is being like hey man
you can't be you can't be sitting there
uh being indecisive you need to figure
out which what call you're gonna make
you need to at least give your guys some
direction
like i'm constantly doing that to these
guys is that happening at ranger school
or is it more like
yeah you know what you this guy ain't
got it yeah they i mean here
the reality is they know if you're not
gonna make it the
your peers know the students know
there's guys who are made for war
and there's guys who aren't made for war
and one of the things
that i think is important about the the
ranger tab and the experience
is you're creating combat leaders
represented by a tap
now now we don't wear tabs necessarily
all over the place because we're in
different uniforms
but when you saw that tab you understood
that that guy was capable as a leader in
combat
and it told a lot so a lot of the times
especially with the officers who come
out of iobc they're brand new 22 year
old
second lieutenants don't give them the
opportunity and they'll say hey
these are the fixes fix this if you
don't fix it you're going to fail
you go to you report to your first duty
station as an infantry officer without a
ranger tab
forget about it your career field for
the you're just now you might as well
just get out
for for young joes like pfcs that i was
for specialists or even young
ncos not commissioned officers you have
an opportunity they'll give you some
feedback
and they expect to see you um take that
opportunity
you might not get another opportunity
based on the cycle of getting patrols
which just means they're going to
recycle and you'll get another chance
uh a month and a half later because
that's how long it takes to get through
it again what's the attrition rate at
ranger school it's pretty high it's
about 80
really yeah it's about 80
so you get you get done with it and now
you must have a pretty freaking good
reputation what are you
are you 19 yet i'm 19. 19.
you graduated from that um so what's
next
so um my uncle
when i'm there was a guard at the tomb
of the unknown soldier
he was there as a guard he was a platoon
sergeant um
before my time and when i'm there i put
a 4187 go to range of time
it doesn't get accepted they're like no
i have a ranger tab
which i thought was a prerequisite to
get a 41.7 they're like no
uh we don't we don't need the numbers
and in 98
they didn't need the numbers 99. and so
i i
talked to my uncle i'm like what do you
want what are my options here
like i'm ready to be in the fight which
there wasn't a fight and that's probably
the reason why i didn't get 4187
approved
they're like um he's like go go try out
for the tomb
and at the time um and still
at that unit the tomb of the unknown
soldier was the most difficult
it's probably the most difficult thing
i've ever done in my life to be honest
selections in special operations
comparatively
were a walk in the park compared to what
that was
i went there the army's been guarding
the tomb of the unknowns
since the the 50s it's been around
um since the uh internment of the world
war one unknown
and it was an honor it was something
that was going to
build me and set me up for success
leading into
potentially battalion or special forces
and so i took the opportunity i went and
tried out
how long is the tryout so you typically
do a
two week try out it's called tdy they
just they tdy you to the tomb
you do a whole bunch of assessments and
then they go you're good enough
or you're not to continue to select and
try
and that's a seven and a nine month
process uh if you're smart
seven months if you're not so smart nine
months so it took me like ten months
so it took me a long time to get my earn
my team identification badge but the
the the process is almost a year and
then what's that job
entail i mean obviously we know what it
looks like from the outside
yeah guarding the tomb but what's it
look like from the inside
it's a suck fest man it's a suck fest i
mean it's it's the most difficult thing
i've done
um but the most honorable uh
responsibility i've been given in the
military
so the tomb of the unknown soldiers have
been guarded by the army
since the the 40s and they guard the
tune 24 hours a day seven days a week
and that rotation takes place in three
release based on height
first being the tallest second being the
mid mid guys and third being the
shortest
minimum six feet tall and then you
rotate basically a firefighter schedule
day on day off day on day off day on and
four days off all year round you know
your schedule for three years in advance
and you typically guard if you're a
guard you have your badge
during the summer time seven walks a day
30-minute walks with a seven-minute
guard change
and then about two to four hours of
guard rotations at night
at night we don't do it in ceremony
uniform it's typically class i think
bees at the time or bdus
and it's a roving patrol your your job
is simply to guard
the tomb of the unknown soldier from
desecration or disrespect
and we we do that snow sleet heat
doesn't matter the weather it's just
being done
what makes the uh what makes it so
challenging to get through the
is it just like microscopic inspections
of your uniforms and your hair and your
freaking nose hairs and your hair here
in your hairs and stuff like that yeah
it's it's the attention to detail
line six of the signals creed states my
standard will remain perfection
and so you build this culture around
paying attention to every single facet
of your
military uniform even your life even
your personal life
of being squared away so i i did that
job and
um you know painful
to be a new guy doing that job but
inspections of your uniform
every single day if not by the hour they
have a culture where you earn a walk you
don't just get a walk
you have to earn that walk so you have
to earn it by understanding knowledge
you have to
verb beta memorize 28 pages of knowledge
about the tomb of the unknown soldier
and the history
of arlington national cemetery because
you're representative you're like you
can go down to do a tomb guard walk
in front of 3 000 people come inside the
quarters change
and go out three minutes later and
communicate the tomb of the unknowns and
what it represents to the us military
so it's a it's a diplomatic position not
just a
a guard wearing a uniform walking back
and forth and so
i remember the my first walk was in
front of 3 000 people
at 12 o'clock noon cnn fox news cameras
were in my face
i remember hearing standing up for arms
hearing the bayonet rattle
on my weapon because you were freaking
nervous because i was nervous i was
standing in front i mean i'm looking
through aviator glasses out of my
peripheral
and see people like inches from me just
staring at me and every movement
during the guard change has to be
perfect and
it's intimidating but it's a sharp
learning curve
and again it's a huge opportunity for me
so the training program or the selection
program that you're talking about
that's 10 months long are you working
during that time are you doing any
guarding
or no you're doing all the guard walks
where there's nobody
watching you early morning late
afternoon and everything at night
i even did what's called a vigil because
i wanted to get the hell away from the
guys
i didn't want to get hazed and abused i
did vigils where
i would work all day and so i'm you know
helping prep the guards uniforms
doing early morning late afternoon walks
and then at night
i'm taking when the cemetery closes at
seven pm
until seven in the morning standing
guard for 12 hours straight
no sleep and guarding just to get away
from the guys
i was like breaking records of doing
[ __ ] i was like doing 21 vigils
back-to-back
so what the hell is going on with the
guys that was so bad
was it just freaking all all in your
[ __ ] all day long
well the so the the tomb of the unknown
soldier the actual badge
is the least awarded badge in the u.s
military besides the astronauts badge
because
you know they're not a dime a dozen
military so
the tim guard badge is is very
much protected by the tim guard badge
protectors
and so they don't want the right guys
there or the wrong guys there they want
the right guys and they
they want to make sure you earn it and i
did and back then
you know hazing um we come from the
military where hazing was normal
i mean if you weren't hazed you didn't
feel like you were loved
like i got my eib my airborne wings my
halo wings punched into my chest
my every rank punched in my collarbone
into the bone
um and that was just the the universe we
uh evolved in
that was very much the case everything
from running through the cemetery trying
to find
you know inscriptions of of specific
people getting smoked
to death low crawling across you know
face down in the lawn
getting you know getting smoked um just
routine hazing to make sure
hey this is a we're testing to
evaluate you constantly if you want to
be here and
it's something that i guess is handed
down in tradition what's the award
ceremony like when you finally get the
badge
not not that big of a deal i mean it's
pretty i i just saw a picture of it i
have a
small 4x6 picture of it and um
the third relief or the third infantry
regiment commander comes down in o6
and he pins your badge on you in the
morning and typically you work the whole
night
take your you take your batch test which
is a a series of specific tests
including
changing the guard at noon
reading verbatim the 28 pages of
knowledge with no errors
being perfect and a written test all
kinds of stuff
and then you get your badge pinned and
you know i'm badge
four 470 out of probably about almost
600 badges today
then how long did you have that job for
that long i did it for about a year and
a half
afterwards and then so for a year and a
half after you went through nine months
of this [ __ ] yeah
they're like okay and this is what
you're doing that's your job that's your
job
and how did you like it so i love
the honor and the duty um but it's not
what i wanted to do in the military
and i i you know one thing we had to do
is maintain our um
common core skill sets so we would come
around the field and those three days
down
we do med training we do raids
patrolling
we had to maintain all these things so
you get
the infantry experience as a part-time
position
representing the army in a full-time
position and it's not what i signed up
for
i mean i was trying to be the best that
i could be be all you could be was the
motto back then
but it's not what i signed up for and
then uh 911 changed
uh everything for me in that in that
situation but how
but where were you stationed when 911
went down so i was
so i got out of the army on my first uh
rotation of four years september 3rd
of 01 was my ets date get on army date
i transitioned into the national guard
because i was going to college
and was a squad leader in the infantry
what was your plan
like federal bureau of investigation hrt
i was like if there's no war if i can't
get into battalion i'm gonna get my
college degree
and i'm gonna go i'm gonna be a sniper
in hrt
um and that was my my sights were set on
that
and when 9 11 happened it was a week
after my ets
and how old are you now 21. so you're 21
years old you get out
on september 3rd september 3rd is when i
left the army
okay yeah so then what do you do so
september 11th comes now you're freaking
you gotta
be going berserk i'm freaking out like
when september 11th happened i was in
the national guard
and i knew the nasty guard was going to
get mobilized
and i'm like i'm not going to worthy no
offense to the national guard but i'm
like i'm not going to war with these
dudes
i immediate like i took i was at college
in the cafeteria in fayetteville near
fort bragg north carolina when this
happened
i went home and threw my battle dress
uniform in the washer
and started packing my stuff because i'm
like we're going to war this is it
and immediately i started making phone
calls and they're like you ain't doing
nothing man
nothing's going on with us right now
stand by to stand by and i'm like i have
to make moves
so i started reaching out to recruiters
and uh
very rapidly got back in the military
and went straight to selection
went straight to green braces was it
hard to get to go straight to selection
there must have been lines out the door
at that point
impossible i was a i was a 20 year old
e5 i mean i made sergeant at 20 years
old
airborne ranger qualified with a tomb
guard badge and
when i showed up to recruiter he looked
at me like i was a
16 year old kid who wanted to play army
and i was like
is this not a thing and at that time
they hadn't even worked out
this whole thing where guys who were
prior servers come back in and serve
i'm like dude i just got out last week
and he's like sorry man you got to start
over
and so i'm duck walking barefoot with a
whole bunch of teenagers
um trying to get back in the army wait
oh cause you had to go back through like
the recruiting process
very beginning i mean i'd have to go to
basic ait i had a ranger tab so i didn't
have to do any of that stuff
but i had to go back through the army
and processing system
called 30th ag from the beginning i'm
duck walking and
i actually went to the recruiting uh
station
uh which is called maps is where they
unprocess you in military uniform
and i remember they brought us in the
room and like everybody stripped down
and guys are looking at me in i'm battle
dressed uniform stripping down and
they're like what
is this dude doing like isn't he a
recruiter like what is happening
and i'm you know in my boxer briefs like
everybody else duck walking
doing all my little drills to get back
in the army
and then you go straight to selection
from there so i went through a program
basically an 18 x-ray program
and i had to try out where it's
basically
special operations preparation course
they evaluate like they did at media
ranger school and said hey
is this kid um is there a probability
that he's going to be successful
let's evaluate him and land nav let's
rock him let's pt him
and his and if he's good we'll give him
a slot so that's that's
prep you just said prep it's the it's
basically uh the preparation for
giving guys slots to go to selection
because they just don't want to throw
you into selection and have you fail
they're setting you up for success and
so i quickly evaluated and they're like
hey this dude's ready let's send him now
how long is that little
evaluation a week okay yeah
it's not straightforward and then you go
to selection
and selection this initial selection is
only a few weeks long right
um when i went to selection it was 21 22
days
yeah a few weeks and this is just sort
of um weeding people out
yeah and making sure you want to be
there yeah i mean
at the time you had to have and you had
to have three years in the army so
you're talking about experience
typically ncos not commissioned officers
or junior enlisted guys who have
experience in the military
and you show up it's a week of
assessment land nav all these gates
to make sure that you're good to go and
then it's team week it's
it's basically a little mini version of
hell week
and then they do the long range the
long-range movement is what gets
everybody it's the
land navigation leading into a
long-range movement where they assess
your ability
as an individual to learn a skill set
and then in the wood line alone execute
that skill set to be successful
and that skill set is just land nav lan
f yeah
it's our trigger it's like you guys is
water we use land
and um hey can you hump for a long
period of time duration day night
and keep moving and can you find your
points and
uh just like the water there's a lot of
people who can't you know it's just this
is crazy
i mean it's to me it's like walking is
very primal
and a lot of people fail yeah yeah you
put that rucksack on it's
not quite walking anymore yes yeah it
sucks the life out of you for sure
what about the first i've always found
like the first 17 minutes with a rock on
i'm always like oh yeah
i remember this [ __ ] yeah where your
body starts to warm up and
everything hurts and then you start
moving i i
i've always been a good rucker that's
always been my strength
and so i never had a hard time with
wrecking my feet were hard
my my back was good so i didn't have a
difficult time with with selection
but um what i saw is a lot of guys
weren't prepared for that
level and duration of movement and it
just broke them down what are you doing
today
in those in that selection where you did
what a week of rocking
what do you think you're doing today uh
on average
six ten to ten kilometers per movement
per gate
um so you know it it depends like
you start that whole entire process
here's the philosophy behind it is
we're going to start moving you and get
you on your feet
and then we'll give you an 18 miler to
20 i think the
the average is a 20 something plus miler
and so you're broke when you start
and then we'll move you for a long
period of time and see
it's all a test on preparation by the
way it's it has nothing to do with the
actual assessment
it has everything to measure whether or
not you prepared in advance
and so what they want is the guys who
prepared in advance
and so at at one point uh for the
long-range movement which is
30 probably 30 plus miles uh over a
period of
24-48 hours you're non-stop moving
and if you bed down for a period of time
and you sit down eat chow
and rack out and you're not timing
yourself appropriately you just fail
and so you have to meet these gates but
it's all
it's all on your own and that that jacks
up people's minds
when somebody comes into a room and
writes down exactly where you gotta be
what uniform you got to be in and what
time you're moving
that independence and setting off with
no destination of mine
hey students i want you to get ready get
your rook on you're going to move until
you
we tell you to stop that immediately
destroys people's uh mindset out the
gate
because they're like what do you mean so
they go out the gate they start
spreading
and they don't pace themselves and they
burn themselves out or
they're so insecure with the
circumstance they impose
they self-induce all the stress and then
they quit and you're like
you're self-selecting because you don't
have the
exact parameters of what you're going to
be doing that's how war is
i mean war is hey we might be flexing
all night we might be flexing all year
who knows and that uncertainty in a lot
of people breaks people down
and they ring out or whatever what do
they do how do you quit
in selection so uh in selection
um in periods of time you go back to
your barracks
and when i went to selection it was a
piece of plywood
no pillow and you have a bunk that has
no pad
nothing nothing comfortable you'll go
you go to sleep in the morning
and you wake up and half of your entire
crew that you went to bed with
is gone and you're like what and so what
people are doing is getting up
they're leaving knocking on the hut and
this self-selecting like literally
saying i'm done
i'm i'm out you have to voluntarily
withdraw
in order and have the conversation in
order to check on a selection
yeah there's something i've always found
about being out in the field and humping
specifically there's two things that
come to mind
and i've been talking about this lately
from just like a leadership perspective
just at my own personal
um mindset is i'm very aware of time
i'm very aware of time i can always feel
time creeping up on me i can always feel
time
like people think oh we'll be able to
make it
we can we can rest a little longer and i
always had that sense that oh
actually no it's not we're not going to
make it in fact we need to leave now if
we're going to make it
or we're sitting there trying to come up
with a plan i say you know what we need
to start
moving forward we can't spend any more
time planning it's time to go
i always had that sense of of time and i
still do and
it's it's almost a level of paranoia
it's something that always is
in the front of my um uh heads up
display right
my head's up display is always going hey
wait check your time check your time
check your time
but that reminds me of being out on
patrols where there are
total dick dragger patrols where you're
carrying a [ __ ] ton of weight and you're
going really far
and you still gotta get to the target on
time
and and the the
the intrinsic motivation that it takes
because once you sit down you take that
load off and you see the guys all
freaking
sitting in a crappy perimeter and just
there they'll sit there
they'll sit there indefinitely like like
you take a platoon out
and and they've gotten their they've
been crushed for a five six seven hour
patrol
they won't get up unless you're like hey
boys
we gotta go and if you if you don't do
that
if somebody doesn't do that somebody
doesn't say hey guys it's time to get up
and go
there's no there will be no movement
what will happen they'll they'll not hit
that target they'll be like hey we
couldn't make the target that's what
will happen
people accept that like yeah you know
what yeah and and so
having that having that intrinsic will
to say look at your watch and go you
know what we we said 10 minute break
it's been nine minutes hey boys get
ready to roll
that's a big deal yes that's a big deal
yeah
i think part of the you know like you
say discipline is freedom part of that
freedom is control
that you have self-control if you
understand
what you have to do to be disciplined to
make gates to meet time hacks
then you have control you're offensive
you're thinking proactively
and a lot of guys don't have the
discipline to do that
it's it's it's uh real crazy to see that
something so simple
a task so common core
can uh weed the masses and evaluate
who's going to succeed
with the combination of aptitude and
discipline versus who's not
yeah and like you just said what it
really boils down to
is when you're tired when you're sore
and when you don't know how much longer
this is gonna last
do you have what it takes to put your
rock back on
stand up and start walking again that's
it yeah
yeah you wouldn't think it's something
that
freaking simple so simple so primal too
so you get through selection and then
you hit the q course hit the q course as
a
18 bravo special forces weapons guy
um going to third special forces group
any any um highlights out of the q
course
no i think you know uh in in the lead in
talking about jfk and the representation
of how we wanted to establish this
irregular and unconventional means of
warfare
i learned that truly from the long
duration that i was in the queue course
i went to robin sage merely
weeks after robin sage after that
experience
i was living that training in
afghanistan in a remote fire base
so robin sage which is an exercise
basically living unconventional warfare
in an environment which is rockingham
north carolina the the surrounding area
where all the civilians are
subcontractors and bought into this
whole thing
this elaborate uh scenario was so
impactful for me
i mean it's crazy yeah so just to give a
little background on this so the the
the mission of the green berets of
special forces
is to go out and work with indigenous
forces get them trained up
get them organized so that they can
fight
by themselves or with very little
guidance from the from the special
forces and eventually with no guidance
at all that's the that's the mission
so the you guys do this big exercise
it's sort of is it like the final
exercise that you do yeah pretty much
yeah and it's called robin sage and you
go out and you have
quote indigenous forces which is really
just the local populace inside this town
and you have to train them and you have
to work with them and you have to get
information from them and set
up targets and the whole nine yards
because that's what the primary mission
of special forces is to go do that
yeah it's by with through it's foreign
internal defense
it's been newly coined counterterrorism
foreign internal defense based on the
wars that we're in now
but it's the idea of you have to build
relationships and rapport
with indigenous people with forces you
just can't go
and do deliberate actions only you know
sr
d a hr those things are complementary to
a strategic plan the strategy
is we have to win the hearts and minds
so when i went to robin sage
you had west pointers like junior west
pointers we had
role players from the military that are
interweaved in this scenario where
you can't just go into this circumstance
and
treat them with a military mind you have
to break bread with them
you have to drink tea with them you have
to learn about their family and build
this relationship
because you have to trust these guys on
target and so
that's what i really took away from
robin sage was this
opportunity to learn and grow in culture
and then build that relationship which
meant
we're building a bond where we could
fight side by side
in the width portion of it and finally
fix and finish these bad guys together
empowering the host nation that we're
doing warfare with
that that's super important because the
the translation of going
into um into war was exactly that with
the circumstance with afghanistan at the
time
and you know like i one of the scenarios
i built conduit
and a chicken coop in a chicken house
for six hours with this guy and i'm like
i'm like looking at the other dude i'm
with him like dude what's going on like
what are we doing right now are we just
are we actually just doing a tasking
and just hooking this dude up because
it's we got tasks to do this
and then at the end of that six hours we
heard a noise and i'm like
it's all coming together we put our m4
we ran in the woods put our m4s together
out of our backpack
and ambushed these two dudes who were
interrogating and bullying this farmer
and i'm like this is so awesome i mean
it's still long
it's a long burn but it was so awesome
as an experience
and then you you so you get done with
anything else in cue course
stands out not survival school i mean
survival school got my ass handed to me
i mean it's the first time that i um
i mean how long is this survival school
it's pretty long i mean
it's probably a few weeks when i went
through it was like a escape
like a survival block yeah it's uh sears
c the high res c
uh c version what you guys have gone
through and then you know you escape you
evade
and then you go into the rtl and just
get your ass handed to you
and and again you learn very rapidly
uh that we're not all created equal in
our capacity to deal with stress
and i dealt fine with it i mean i i grew
up fighting i grew up
in martial arts i grew up doing all
these things which set me up for success
there to go
hey man this is an exercise learn from
this experience wait what martial arts
did you grow up in
ninjutsu before straight up
who wants something dude i my first
instructors were all green berets at
fort bragg north carolina who opened in
ninjutsu school
active and former sf guys and
it was gangster we were doing stuff like
my mom once
wait did you have them shoes with the
toe cut out oh yeah oh look at you
you're like sure i had all the freaking
yeah you were just getting it it was
crazy i was wondering who was buying all
that stuff out of the back of freaking
oh black belt magazine i had the catalog
it was it was
i had all the red knives all the it was
crazy it was a it was a
cool experience because my guys that
were the instructors
were all green berets and so they
like you do like a lot of guys with our
experiences do
try to impart those experiences and
impact on young people
and so they're doing the same with me so
i felt like i was mentored by these
green berets
once i went into a class and my mom
dropped me off
and for my mom to be paying for this
course is a big deal
she dropped me off and she saw the
instructor put me in front of a mirror
and she came back an hour and ten
minutes later and i was still standing
in front of the mirror
and she was pissed off because she's
like am i i'm paying for my son
why are you doing why are you only
having him stand there it's like it's an
assessment and i stared at myself for an
hour in meditation i'm like what the
hell i learned a lot about myself
in that hour it's crazy
all right so uh back to back to
did you did wait before we go there did
you guys fight each other in
school a lot it was aggressive a lot of
dudes got hurt
it was just i think it was a lot before
what years was this uh 93-94
ufc just coming out yeah people were
this is what during the revolution
oh yeah oh yeah it was a lot of i mean
there were
i mean ninjutsu has uh in in this
japanese form has a lot of traditional
uh jiu-jitsu type moves on the ground
but it's not ground
game
that's the problem that is the problem
that's an inherent problem with
with that and so i i i learned a lot
about discipline from that experience
but it made me harder so when i went to
survival school
i was just prepped man i was good and it
wasn't a difficult thing but i saw dudes
fall apart
and when i went to survival school it
was the last thing that you did
in the q course if you failed
you failed everything you just you just
spent two years of your life
training to be a green beret and they
let dudes go how many people
fail that we'd have a couple per class i
mean it was it was common to have a
couple per class that would self-select
and they'd be like i'm done
you're like you just did two what's
making them quit
the stress man what's stressful well i
mean getting a like
even just the hood like people aren't
used to taking if you if you don't grow
up in those martial arts if you don't
grow up in
um impact sports and not used to making
contact
when that hood comes off your head and
you get slapped by a dude's
hands who are like pickle fingers mcgee
and he slaps your face
and and you can't do anything that
starts breaking you down
and by you know day two of that
experience
you know laying naked in your cell flex
cuff in a box
a lot of guys self-select i thought it
was i was
into claustrophobia i like being in
small places
i i hid i slept and i was like this is
awesome just keep me in this box
man i got slapped so hard when i got
captured at sears school
the it surprised me yeah like it was
i mean this guy freaking out of nowhere
the hood comes off i'm standing up
against a wall it's out in the middle of
the woods and they have like a wall
and i think it's almost like a hollywood
wall where it when you get pushed into
it it kind of
gives a little bit yeah yeah so he
pushed me into it once and like whatever
i
must have had some kind of punk ass
freaking smirk on my face like
whatever and this dude did not like it
at all and
he cracked me i mean i'm talking as hard
as a human being can
i mean i've been punched in the face it
was like that but his hand happened to
be open
and i i got the little uh got the little
flash and i was like oh damn
this is real i was like yeah and believe
me that was that was
number one because he followed that one
up
um yeah but i like you i i can't imagine
that
that would have made me quit but i guess
if someone's not used to
you know maybe scrapping and whatnot
that's it yeah a lot of people
not really for them yeah i had what the
interesting thing in the psychology was
you're playing you have to be resistant
right the whole game is you're resistant
i remember we were building um in the
sand
a sickle that represented the communist
you know scenario and we were building a
sickle
and half of us were sabotaging the
sickle so guys would make it
and i remember i had a guy who i highly
respected he was platoon started in the
infantry
had gone through training with me i was
scooting all the stuff out after they
were building it
knocking it over and he turned around
and he walked to me because what are you
doing
i'm like uh what do you mean what i'm
doing like dude i like worked an hour on
that
i'm like wait a minute you realize that
we're supposed to be
subverting this whole circumstance like
you're not supposed to actually be
making this
and he's like oh and he was in the
scenario man
freaking bridge on the river kwai oh
dude it was insane some of these guys
were like the headlights
i mean it was they had the deer in the
headlights look and they thought for
real
they were in the back country of vietnam
i mean it was
it was crazy it was crazy to see it but
cool cool experience
go ahead what kind of claustrophobia
stuff did they yeah
a lot of it was um this this guy right
here is kind of claustrophobic yeah
we've been working with them yeah yeah
exposure's the way to deal with that but
it's it they had i mean
it was it was very um
tight secluded spaces where you couldn't
sit down on your butt
and you couldn't stand up all the way so
you're in an uncomfortable stress
position
and then they would close the box on you
and turn up the lights um and then they
play the music
like crying babies all kinds of
different stuff
and a lot of people um they would
transfer you into different boxes based
on your fear
so if they saw the fear coming out of
you they were exploiting that fear
they're like oh this dude in a big box
is getting scary let's put them in a
small box and so it varied from small
boxes to big boxes
um but it it that jacked up a lot of
people i mean it was
it was significant and then how long do
you have to stay in there
so a long time you you lose track of
time because you're sleep deprived
here's one story i i thinking i was a
smart guy
i i was like similar to the i have to
piss right now but i had to piss really
bad
and so i'm like if i piss in this box
they're going to hook me up i can't piss
in this box
so this is my i'm thinking logically i
think
and i'm like this is completely logical
wait so hook me up is a bad thing hook
like like pull me out of the thing and
slap my face off my
face and i'm like look i'll piss in my
boot
and then i'll take it outside and we're
in the gravel i'll dump the piss off
forgetting about this whole thing called
displacement right
i pee in my boot i take off my boot you
don't have socks you're naked
get these bare pajamas on i fill my boot
with piss and then i'm like okay i got
it in here
i feel good it's not all over the thing
and then i put my foot back in the boot
damn
and then it goes everywhere and i'm like
and then it immediately occurs to me
like that was a horrible idea
and so i'm standing in piss and then my
foot my naked foot is covered in piss
and i'm like dude that did not work out
i had a plan that was not how i thought
i was going to execute it was horrible
man
yeah it's funny because as you were
thinking about that was you were talking
about that and then when you asked that
question echo
you know there's some look i don't know
if this is some um
you know just straight up sam harris
meditation
type scenario but you get your brain
where you just aren't there anymore yeah
you're just like cool you wanna put me
in the box cool
and you're sitting there and you're
thinking about freaking whatever
kentucky fried chicken and lemonade
and what and you're just in a totally
different world and
you don't know if it's been an hour or
five hours
and you're getting slapped it's like
cool whatever
like whatever they're gonna do to you
you you just sort of
and it's the same thing when we were
talking earlier about humping a rock
it's like okay look there's just
i'm not the pain is there but it's like
somewhere else like
it's almost like you're watching it
happen and you kind of can be like yeah
whatever
hey keep going yeah completely you're
you're
you're sedated man you're just going
with the flow it's it's similarly to i
think about
when you accept at some point when
you're in water that you're just gonna
pass out
and you accept that you're like i'm okay
with that that bridge in that gap and
just
accepting it is the the first part in
being successful in that environment
and then you like you create your new
happy place where you're like man
as long as i'm in my head and i have
this space that i'm comfortable with i'm
good you could do whatever you want
there's nothing you can do
yeah if you are present in the
[ __ ] that you're going through yeah
that's gotta suck i can't even i can
barely even relate to it because
i i think eventually you just get good
at being like okay cool whatever that's
what we're doing
cool whatever i can't it's got a real
that's what that's you know what that
when i start thinking about what makes
someone quit
it's because they're present in that
[ __ ] that's going down they're actually
in it yeah and now they're in it they're
looking at the future going it's just
more [ __ ] in the future so
oh this is horrible and forget it i'm
going to ring out yeah
it's that fear response it's the
contemplation of impending doom where
you're just thinking about the next
thing that's coming and then your whole
life is all these little small
progresses of like
doomsday doomsday doomsday it's like
dude i'm i'm on the beach
drinking a pina colada eating a piece of
chicken right now i'm
i'm living my best life in my head and
i'm good you must have learned some of
that the tomb
situation because that stuff doesn't
sound fun to me
i would rather go through school 20
times right now than yes do uniform
inspections
i would rather do that as well i would
take the the tomb taught me
about um self-awareness
and being present within my own mind
and developing this relationship with
the conscious voice that's in my head
but also like this passive observer this
person who's
kind of observing the narration of the
voice in my head
and sitting back and like measuring all
these inputs
because when you're standing still for
21 seconds at a time
before you take 21 steps repeating it
times an
hour for a long walk during the winter
hours
times four to six walks a day you have
to get real good at
being comfortable with yourself is there
a facing movement in there
there is so it's um you face washington
dc
21 seconds face down the mat 21 seconds
walk 21 steps and repeat
for the entire duration uh and it's one
hour
one hour and seven minutes with the walk
and the guard change
how often would you be in total
autopilot where you'd get done and be
like oh that was
constantly checked constantly you you
know that that
that's referred to as the flow state
you're completely in a flow state
because
you're what i like about you you're
talking about time
time has always been an important metric
in fact we should probably get more
closely because
that relationship with time i think sets
and establishes
these gates and disciplines for your
whole life the structure of your life
right
when i was a tomb guard um one thing
that you had to train to do is
count 21 seconds exactly and then turn
into face for 21 seconds and get this
rhythmed and cadence down
but when you got into that flow state it
was unconscious
so now i'm just on autopilot and i'm in
a meditative state
there's times that i came off um the mad
after an hour walk
and feeling like the best i've ever felt
like super calm super relaxed super
focused
and like i was doing meditation in my
own head space
that translated throughout all of the
uncomfortable
even experiences and gunfights and
everything else i did in my life
created a structure in my head for being
comfortable
in my own head in physical stress
in my environment sometimes when i do
jiu jitsu
i don't really know what happened for
the last hour yeah like i'm just like
what how did you get that i'm like i
don't remember getting anything yeah
and i remember early on in my uh in my
seal career
like entering a room and shooting some
targets and then and then all of a
sudden be like wait a second is my
weapon i put my weapon on safe did i put
whatever not safe and not want to draw
any attention to myself because i don't
want anyone to see that i don't know
what
my weapon was on safe yeah i did it
without and then you know did it
absolutely without thinking about it
that was pretty early
you know and eventually you're just like
doing this like a freaking robot
that's just executing yeah that that
high level i mean it's theta and alpha
and these these wavelengths of like this
neurological consciousness
when you're in that alpha state and
you're taking that information similar
to like
uh when you're in a shower on a drive
and all these thoughts come to you this
creativity comes to you
those things happen in that flow state
because you're streaming information
and that's when you're most i think when
you're
at your best right it's when you're
flowing in cqb
and everything comes together and you're
like what just happened like we we were
just objective secure in 17 seconds
how did that happen i i barely remember
anything but i was so conscious
because you're in that alpha state of
flow it's it's a it's an amazing state
to be in
and i think very rare for people to find
these days with the distractions they
have
you wrap up the q course the last thing
you do is robin sage working with
you know role-playing in dige and then
you said you're almost immediately in
afghanistan
right out the gate deploy with third
special forces group on a mountain team
and then do nine months in afghanistan a
remote firebase
just right off the gate right out the
gate during operation red wing my
company was involved in red wings
when i got to a team it was the
traditional green beret mission
we're going to put you in a remote fire
base on the border of afghanistan and
pakistan
as an 18 bravo i had 150 afghan soldiers
that weren't even soldiers this is
before
afghan national army was even stood up
and solidified
especially in our region of nuristan
province
and we trained assisted and advised
these guys
made them afghan special forces guys and
started conducting operations in
nuristan
what kind of operations were you
conducting movement to contact
we did sr um special reconnaissance
we did d.a a lot of training
um and a lot of getting attacked i mean
we got
attacked every other day in the remote
location that we're in we're the
furthest for uh
northern firebase beyond jbad
beyond assad abad in a firebase called
naray
right on the border surrounded by the
hindu kush
i mean we were at the bottom of that
bowl so rockets and direct attacks
almost every other day
and so we did a lot of direct um you
know react to contact
immediate action drills and a lot of
patrols
i mean we drove up and down one msr i go
to that went to parakaut
um and you know eventually ended up in
chatral pakistan
and conducted uh a whole bunch of air
ops and ground ops in that area
was this like a traditional oda team of
10 or 12 guys
12 guys with a small contingent of
civil affairs for a period of time one
combat controller
and a firebase two hours from air in
jbad
so as remote as you can get i mean we
were self-sustained
i i learned a lot even fast forwarding
with uh
how i teach survival and sustaining
oneself
and what we call just homestead as we
teach it
about how you have to take care of
yourself because you don't have the
opportunity
uh in those remote circumstances to
depend on any kind of assets
i mean a snowstorm in that area would
shut us down for a week at a time
where we get no air support no air
support no casts
no resupply no medevac platforms
so we are solely dependent on the men
and their skill sets that they have
based on their experiences
that's freaking sketchy it was the wild
west the greatest time i had in sf
to be honest we didn't have a flagpole
we had
simple 5ws for con up submissions it was
it was a good time
and did you realize that while you were
doing it
i did i had the introspect i mean when i
remember when i showed up
and um we landed at 10 000 plus feet of
elevation
and i was pissing mellow yellow i mean i
was like dude this is insane
and i look i remember standing in the
middle of my fire base we were along
konar river
um very small base i mean i could throw
a football and hit every gate
i remember looking around going well
this is my home for almost a year
get comfortable with this because this
is how it's going to be and
immediately transforming and using those
cultural tactics and building
relationships
but getting comfortable with time
because i didn't know when we were going
to get out i didn't know if we were
going to survive
we lost a lot of guys that rotation
operation red wing had happened
so there's a whole bunch of
circumstances that happened during that
trip where i'm like
dude this might be it i mean this this
is a pretty hot circumstance
are you gonna get out of this stop
thinking about that it's like the
character in band of brothers that the
officer who said you know who's
basically is walking dead just accept
the fact that you're gonna get killed
i had those kind of moments going this
is it man we're
focused on the mission and it changed a
lot of how i
what i assumed at war in practice
and how it executed in real life a lot
of it was theory and concepts
and didn't necessarily translate or what
i discovered what was the delta between
the two
the biggest thing was my relationship um
in the oda was teaching tactics and
creating a base defense plan
and so the doctrine told me to do
specific things
that didn't work in our environment so
you had a base defense plan for example
where
i would exercise my guys and say hey i
want you to hit the walls hit the roof
be prepared for that direct attack
well that's the dumbest tactic when
you're receiving 107 millimeter rockets
that have a kill radius of 100 yards
and so you put dudes on the roof which i
did myself on the first
uh direct attack got on the roof with a
240 machine gun
and i'm like dude what am i and i'm
getting and we a 107
screamed over me my 18 charlie my
engineer and
impacted a fuel blivet behind us and
exploded
and i'm like what am i doing and also
in practice you could immediate action
to death
what it's like to react to contact with
small arms but how do you react
to contact when it's a 107 millimeter
rocket when it's an 81 millimeter
mortar all of the things that you
prepare for
change rapidly when that kind of
ordinance
and munitions and firepower come to bear
completely changes everything
so i'm like oh this isn't like running
through the wood line in fort bragg
north carolina
this is a little bit different and so
that changed my perspective on
a doctrinal conventional answer and
solution
versus being creative and coming up with
new ways and tactics
as you evolve at the speed of war did
you guys have any
um counter battery or any anything like
that
none i had did you have mortars i had
120 millimeter mortars
i mean nightly that i would go out and
we'd be dropping on on point of origin
sites on poo sites
um but that's all we had um the biggest
weapon systems we had
were munitions and and caches that we
found
and caches that we found where we took
them and turned them around on bad guys
we bought a mark 21
107 millimeter pod we get one rocket
from the bad guy
the sit rep would read you know oda 366
responds with 57 107 millimeter rockets
106 millimeter recordless rifles we had
mounted the atvs
we had rpgs that we carried with us in
backpacks
and we were using chinese-made 120s to
respond and react to contact
so it was truly a i think a
significant green beret firebase mission
you ever seen the movie heat before yeah
yeah this makes me think about this is
the second time i've thought about it in
recent
times but you know like um
the cop is telling that the the cop is
saying hey
you can make mistakes or no i can make
mistakes doesn't matter if i catch you
or not
like i'm gonna go home at night yeah you
make one mistake and it's game over
yeah and and that's what i think of you
know the enemy in that situation
they don't have to take very big risks
at all they can lob
[ __ ] at you from wherever and they just
have to get lucky one time that's a to
get a guy
yeah and you've got to be vigilant all
the time
and you got to keep your guard up all
the time and even if you keep your guard
up all the time you're still just
exposed just by the nature of the fact
that you're in a valley surrounded by
indirect fire or direct fire in terms of
rockets
yeah yeah our strategy in that firebase
um was a test bed for creativity
um we built a mosque like i physically
built a mosque with my hands my oda
brick by brick helped build a mosque why
because we wanted to build rapport
with having a place of
worship inside of our firebase for
afghans but it also deterred indirect
fire
because no terrorists wanted to be
responsible for dropping a mosque in the
middle of an american fire base
like we had to think outside the box and
um we truly were set up almost for
failure in that circumstance
but every firebase had to hold its
territory
before vso where village stables
stabilization operations where you're
setting up in the actual village
the idea of firebase is derived from
obviously from vietnam er
from john schrecker meyer error of hey
let's go out set out these bases
and establish a presence and so were
present and the bad guys knew about it
and it was a
sharp learning curve steep learning
curve to say the least where are you
getting food from
uh typically uh in initially we were
flying it in until we started getting
creative we built a
a bread house where we were making foot
bred afghan foot bread in the middle of
our fire base
then we started procuring goats and
sheep and then slaughtering them and
then eating them
and then rice and we were getting
supplies from pakistan
uh because it was right across the
border and bringing it in
to to make actually good mills versus
the mermaid child that we're getting
that was garbage
it was disgusting did you uh did you
take any casualties from all those
attacks yeah i mean we've had we had
wounded in actually i killed an action
on a company
um we you know during the mid
range um which was we just had the
anniversary
of operation red wings which was the
28th of june
we got hit up for that mission task for
that with that um
camp vance which was in bagram kind of
assembled the
quick reaction force that eventually
went out and lost one of the birds
on the mh-47s that were shot down so we
did qrf for that
um did some big operations in what kotya
valley near bear account
and took casualties we lost mh47
during that trip um pretty expensive
bird but it was
i mean it was overall it's a good trip i
mean our our firebases were successful
in disrupting the enemy
but we just started over man the the
detriment
to warfare is this vicious cycle
and when you take a playbook and you
plan the playbook
but you don't put in the same continuity
pieces to establish a long-term
relationship
you just start the vicious cycle all
over again every detachment commander
every team sergeant wants their
mark in history on that battleground and
it doesn't do well long term in in
warfare
which is obviously where the point we're
at today i mean pulling out of
afghanistan
what'd you do during red wing we you
were on the recovery op
so uh two of my companies in asada bad
and jbad um south of us got tasked to
actually do
the uh rescue of marcus citroel so
a good buddy of mike kent was the ground
force commander for that
two odas and then the rangers went in
with some
intermittent special operations guys we
got told because of our
proximity to the actual site crash site
uh to hold fast they sent chinooks to us
to be the qrf
for the other group and then the rest of
our company all the other odas did the
body recovery with uh battalion
so there was a the whole company was
involved in some way but i sat on an
airfield for
the entire operation not doing much
so your leadership lessons on that
deployment were
you know you got to think you got you
can't follow the doctrine all the time
yeah look green berets are known
to be unconventional and irregular
warfare experts and
thinking outside the box this idea of
hey you're not stealing you're acquiring
these creative
tasks to bear that
benefit you on the ground is what i
learned about i actually learned
that you know being in a remote firebase
in afghanistan
with minimal to no resources at all
it you had to come up with solutions so
i learned
about establishing problem sets coming
up with creative solutions
and the path to execution for those
which is a
formula that i used in you know a combat
rotations later
and you're running a company of 150
afghans yep yeah i ran so i was the
when i went i was the only bravo
typically you run a junior and a senior
i would have been the junior because i
was a young staff sergeant um
my senior had surgery so he couldn't
show up until later on in the deployment
my team started came to me like on the
first day and he said hey there's a
formation outside with your guys i'm
like my guys
like yeah you got 150 afghans out there
you're the commander and i'm like what
am i roger that i go outside i'm like
guys
let's uh let me give you an in brief
let's we're going to do assessments i
give them the plan
and i i have to build rapport with these
dudes these dudes are looking at me like
i'm a child and i was i mean i was a 25
year old child
so they challenged me immediately one of
the guys
says to me um mike uh
they want to know if you're a good
shooter and
i said well what does that assessment
look like you know
well what they like to do and i'm like
okay so this has been done before
what they like to do is take a piece of
bubble gum wrapper and they delaminate
it
and they put a one inch square at 25
yards on the target
and they said whoever gets closer
whoever is closer wins
but then you earn our respect i'm like
did you guys watch a movie man is this
like
is this the thing because i don't i
don't remember seeing this anywhere and
like
it's it's part of their tradition okay
cool so we're getting the prone
and i said so it's rifle not it's rifle
ak-47 so but
no red dot iron sights and i don't even
know the point of aim or impact on this
gun there's no dope
oh it's a random random ak yeah so i
said
so i say to the guy i said um this is
the same weapon that you shoot
at the circus at the little red star
exactly
exactly notching the star out the county
fair so
he he sits down and he's a
well-respected neurostanding these guys
look like me i mean i
i look like i belong in that tribe and
they're all chinese influenced
and so they always got the the asian
eyes and so rapport initially right off
the bat
is like accepted but i have to prove
myself so this guy gets down on the
prone and he takes a shot
and we go up and inspect it and he's
like an inch off of the pasty so i'm
thinking in my head
he's holding it and he's shooting it but
he's a little bit high
and at 25 yards flash to bang not much
change at muzzle velocity at 25 yards
so i'm thinking let me just aim at the
base of this thing
so i put my i i lolly pop this uh one
inch pasty
and i break a shot and it goes through
the the piece
and i try to contain my excitement
because i'm like
yeah i don't want to be like yeah what's
up but i knew it was part of the
this whole story in this journey so i go
up there and they
they bust out and they're like yeah oh
my god and they're so excited
and from that moment it's like i was
their commander
and we have this relationship where i
trained them every single day i broke
bread with them every single day
and it was a beautiful thing man i felt
like i had a company
worth of valuable human beings who would
lay down their life
and and when i found out later and this
is this is in hindsight looking back and
talking to different guys
when i left i had those afghan commandos
i handed them over to another oda when
third group came back in they rotated in
and there was a guy by the name of uh
uh rob uh rob
i can't remember rob something i can't
remember his name he's horrible i can't
remember his name
and he rotated in with him as the 18
bravo so
when he gets in that position he starts
grooming these guys and they're telling
stories
of of that circumstance so
as this evolves later in the war
i find out that one of the guys that we
had from third group that was killed
posthumously in a gunfight running
uphill
with a machine gun um gets killed
earns the medal of honor and dies
fighting side by side with these same
guys in fact some of those guys that i
trained
were killed in that action where
uh a third guy won the medal earned the
medal of honor
sacrificed his life but those afghans
died on that same hilltop running uphill
against an enemy machine gun nested
position
and i'm like dude i mean you know you
look for
all the the light and darkness and i'm
like man
that that means the world to me that
maybe i had an impact on these men
that stood side by side and and fought
uphill and
that that truly meant a lot and so those
guys um
you earned their respect you operate
with them but when i left him it was it
felt like the end of the world
and you know you talk to guys like john
striker meyer that's a common theme
it's something that we're not very good
at in fact we're
pretty horrible at and now of course you
must be kind of sick to your stomach
seeing that we're pulling out
and those guys will either be
rounded up and killed or they'll join
the taliban
because that's what they got to do to
stay alive more likely all the intel
has been leaked already they already
know who they are and their they have
their target deck built
and right now i mean if you look at all
the different places especially the
remote
places of afghanistan which is very
tribal very geographically regionally
they're already taken over i mean
they'll have the estimates
from the experts is in the next six
months bagram
and kenar will fall to the taliban if
not sooner because there was a formal
agreement a diplomatic agreement
that means they're supposed to take over
in some capacity anyway
but what that means to the rest of the
men that we fought off all over the
country
all these guys will be rolled up and
more likely executed which is a
it's a it's a damn shame yes
um hearing some reports that the taliban
would
go to you know some of these villages or
whatever and send a note into the police
chief and say
hey man um yep it's over you can get on
board or we're gonna kill you and kill
your family
and the police chief or whatever the
local afghan leaders
like roger that you know i'm on board
and that's that yeah those guys
just like in iraq um just like i've
experienced in yemen
in pakistan um in africa
um it's a vicious cycle
that doesn't stop and we don't learn
those lessons
um but i don't know the answer i don't
know the solution i mean
making them citizens and bringing them
up taking the fighting force that's the
most capable human beings there and
doing that
i don't know what the answer is but it's
uh it's a horrible thing that i know is
transpiring likely right now
so you get done with that deployment yep
get done with uh
afghanistan immediately come back and go
to uh
sephardic which is our version of
advanced cqb hostage
rescue to be aligned with a d a company
you know the
when i work with the the seals and 0607
all the the latter rotations it was
mostly with
a company called the commander in
extremist force which has now been
renamed the
crisis response force which has been
recoined a deep underground
um unit for uh tunnels and stuff so
get part of that unit which our focus is
d a sr
hr and get through sephardic no problems
and get immediately reassigned to the
commanders in extremist force which is
hopping on a plane uh the next month
to go downrange so how long are you home
for four months
home for four months and how long was
that deployment to afghanistan
nine months total yeah so nine months
get back
do sephardic for two months and then get
about a month and a half
before we burn out for iraq for baghdad
have you like gotten married or anything
at this point yeah i i i forgot about
that i actually got
married right before this rotation
and in a courthouse my grandmother
passed away at that same time
period didn't get a lot of time to to
have any kind of
anything with the family and then we
were turning and burning for iraq
four months home and now what's this
deployment so this is now your first
deployment to iraq
first development to iraq yeah going
down range and
ct is the and this is oh six
oh six yeah and so you ended up
working in baghdad in baghdad yeah
baghdad international airport
man we were at camp uh not at camp vance
uh area four
okay yeah so we staged area four had a
couple of mission sets you know
working with iraqi counterterrorism
forces working
with task force as a unilateral force
and then working with the
eru which is the emergency response unit
the
the equivalent of the fbi hrt that
prosecutes targets in iraq
iraqi that's an iraqi unit yeah
like the mic force until you know the
mike force strike unit
until we get there and we start doing
joint operations with
navsof and then the sif so it's it's
like a couple guys from
my sif company which was b23 the third
group stuff
working hand in hand with six or seven
guys from a facilitator
and we would go out and at the time we
weren't they weren't doing operations
with americans because
a company a contracted company was
training them
but they weren't advising them but they
weren't doing counterterrorism
operations
so we actually took over and started
doing the first counter-terrorism
operations with them
side by side um using our assets to bear
but doing uh the true ct for an internal
defense mission
so you're rolling out hitting targets
hitting targets yeah every night it's
basically what this is
smashing targets every night i mean our
our pdss our pre-deployment
deployment site survey we got in a
gunfight and killed dudes in our pdss
so we were like it's going to be a hot
year and that was the year you were
there yeah
yeah i was over in ramadi you guys were
down in baghdad and
you're working alongside some of the
guys i was with well that i knew
over there um
just basically nightly ops reverse cycle
nightly ops we had a cycle of
you know red amber green you're training
dudes um even if you're training dudes
you're probably gunning
on truck trucks or acting as a machine
gunner on halves on helicopter assaults
but every single night we're prosecuting
targets sometimes two three targets a
night depending on what's going on
so we had a target deck everybody else
in task force had a target deck
and at the time which was um
in transition for the big surge
we were prosecuting at the time um
shia based targets and so um mokta
al-sadr
and his network of [ __ ] we were
going after
yeah every night were you working mostly
in and around baghdad or all over the
country
pretty much all over the country i mean
we have with uh navy assets
flying us out the 60s um we were using
pavlo
or the 53 um or you used some tassource
160th so
little birds 60s depending on what was
going on
it was all over all over and what was
your specific job
on this deployment so i was i was an
assaulter i mean in the sift i was an
assaulter i was a breacher
i actually was deployed with um at the
time jeremy wise
jeremy wise was a young east coast-based
sale team member
who winded up getting killed with the
cia as a global response staff officer
he posthumously was awarded the cia star
um and we were both preachers together
so we every night we did breaches we
did unilateral pieces of our op so a
couple americans like me and another sif
guy and like three or five
seals would go out and do our piece we'd
hit one building
and then the iraqis we were with would
hit another building so
unilateral assaulters is basically what
we were this is
radically different deployment than what
you did in afghanistan i mean like not
even the same
freaking ballpark insane completely
different i try to use some of the
you know the similarities where we were
training them in the back end but they
were these guys
if you saw them operating when they're
kid you would think they're americans
like competent
assaulters snipers americans yeah they
had all american gear and weapons
because
yeah i was telling you i went over on
pdss and
because we were gonna go i actually if
that would have happened i would have
been co-located with you and we would
have been running the same app we would
already know each other we'd be
bros yeah we'd be rolling together yeah
we'd have rolled out but
we ended up not going there we ended up
going to ramadi instead but yeah the the
the ictf and the eru had
like american issued weapons they had
night vision had everything
everything they had everything yeah they
had everything and they were well
trained
well-trained they had to be the best
ira and most reliable iraqi soldiers by
a landslide
yeah the combination of the iraqi
counter-terrorism force which we pulled
out of
iraq and jordan and isolating train and
the eru
that turned into the emergency response
battalion
were the highest paid
trained experienced units that
eventually took isis
these same guys like i lost probably
half my fighting force that i worked
with over the years
against the fight against isis in 2014
when we pulled our guys out
and those dudes went to war i mean they
went to missoula they went to baghdad
they went to
kurdistan they were fighting their bill
they were
probably with close air support meaning
the jtac piece
for the sole reasons that isis doesn't
exist in iraq today so
it's it's a it was a long road ahead of
them we were just in the beginning
stages of it
what did you prefer for for the
deployment what did you like doing
better
man that's a tough question so different
so different right but in the things
that i enjoyed like
over landing across afghanistan and the
wild west
uh with not a lot of oversight
and just winging it and learning a lot
of lessons in that
versus that deliberate like land on the
x fast rope on top of the building
and kill bad guys i enjoy them both i
mean if i could have if i could overland
to an objective and fast rip on top of
it that whole culmination
it'd be perfect man i love both of them
and then how long was this deployment to
baghdad six months
yeah so we were doing six month
rotations did you did you guys take any
casualties on that deployment
we did we took uh every deployment that
we wanted him taking we wound up losing
a team guy
um so we were working with joint task
force which included tier one units and
the rangers um and us and this and the
navy
you guys were taking casualties um there
was efps that were
affecting guys gun fights uh we took a
casualty
one of my guys in my troop was killed
that rotation uh tongue nguyen
um was killed and then um we had a ton
of
purple hearts dudes getting gun fights
um it was it was an active year
was uh was tongue the first guy that you
lost that was in your
actual element yeah and that was on my
team in my troop
first first dude um
didn't know him great i mean i knew him
i was a new guy there
but one of the uh most respected members
of that unit i mean he was the guy
on the pdss with his long gun who wound
up killing like three bad dudes on a
pdss
i mean who goes tdy and kills a few
dudes comes back
after you know getting into like you got
some intel on target
you know he he was that kind of guy
vietnamese descent too
so um me and him were the only asians in
that group and
he took he took uh um
he he took his job serious and when he
saw me come into the company he took me
under his wing
and and he tried to take care of me
experienced assaulter belonged to c11
which is the first group
uh sif and did a whole bunch of
operations in the philippines all over
southeast asia
and just a highly respected dude i'm
just a great guy
and when in how deep in deployment was
that um man right off the gate i mean it
was only a couple months in
uh we still had uh four months of that
rotation
and then at the end of our rotation was
the surge so we got super hot super
active
um probably some of the closest
experiences to death
i had in that in that rotation for for
me personally
from gun fights from ieds now gun fights
i mean i was on a uh a rooftop in sadr
city once
in a sniper overwatch position for a
hostage rescue got pinned down to the
roof
um i had a big army sniper team that was
with me
that that one and a half hour gunfight
small arms rpgs water rounds
all in the same um gunfight all on our
position
um i'll never forget i was like you know
laying on the roof trying to keep my
head flat
and staying in the fight because we had
a retreat option we could have went down
in the
into the building into the third story
that we were on and i looked over and my
buddy chris
because there's only two of us with a
big army sniper unit
was um laying underneath the satellite
dish
and we're three stories high so we're
above
most of the city but there's still
second and third story buildings inside
saunders city
and he's getting the satellite dish
disintegrated over his ass
a couple feet over his butt and i'm like
oh
these guys are close they have us dot
they have us dialed in
and then i looked up in the sky because
i something caught my attention i looked
up and there's rpgs air bursting above
us
and i'm like this is not good so we
we basically started waylaying bad guys
that were
squirting into the objective like trying
to infill on containment
and that we're breaking contact out of
the objective and all black mighty
militia dudes black pajama kind of guys
and um a lot of it was command and
control
because we had cass i had control
i had coms with a close air support f16
that was above us
and we were trying to relay and report
all the information but we were having
comms problems
so what lulled that fight you know in
the long story of it
um what lulled that fight was an f-16
uh because i marked a vs 17 panel in the
middle of that roof
came out of its rotation its orbit
and over 500 feet above our building did
a pass
and pop flares i thought he was going to
do a gun run and kill us all because we
lost comms
so i popped that vs17 and i looked up
and he started banking in
and i'm like i yelled at my combo guide
i'm like do we have any comms
and he came down and ran the perimeter
road which i think was um
used to call it home base where at the
base of the leg of solder city from home
base to third base
he ran that entire road at 500 feet
turned his wings you could almost see
his
his face and pop flares and it lulled
the gunfight enough for us to get out
break contact into bradley's
and break contact yeah we killed i mean
total during that up over 100 dudes and
gotta shut down for like a month on a
solder city became a big
i mean tanks were tanks were destroying
buildings five feet in front of them
because they were i mean they were just
getting smashed with rpgs and everything
else
pretty pretty gnarly gunfight and that
was the that was the end of your
deployment in o6 uh
about mid rotation that was that was
about mid rotation
good times
you come back do another workup
uh instant workup getting ready for a
new deployment
and then we go down range um
07's different beast
the the height of al qaeda um on the
tail end of that rotation the surge
begins the sunni strategy
uh they start the sons of iraq they
start empowering sunnis
you know there's a war going on between
the sunnis and shias and
typically it's like you know dick sauter
city versus everybody else in the
country
and now the sunnis are getting supported
by the us
so we're going to war with um iran back
shias
and we get into that rotation
and our task force does a couple things
they
have a mission set where they go hey you
guys are going to go and do bilateral
operations working with indigenous guys
like ictf like eru like we
like we talked about but there's another
component our mission set
where we work with jsoc joint task force
so we were under a joint task force
conducting counterterrorism operations
hunting hvts on a deck um
for jsoc as part of one of their action
arms
that whole entire rotation and it was it
was epic
it was one of my best rotations so this
is now oh seven you're back over there
oh seven iraq yeah
in baghdad again uh yeah we're at uh
fernandez mss fernandez
uh named after a unit guy was killed and
you're doing and you're doing
one hit you're working with the indige
one night and then
two nights later you get a package from
jay sock and you're going out and hit
that target
so we divided our troops oh okay so my
troops just doing unilateral
we're just killing bad guys landing on
the x every night just kind of yeah
that was great yeah that was that was
how how big is your unit that you're
working with 20 so our troop is about 20
plus guys
and at the time i'm a sniper now so i
moved over to the sniper section so
i'm a sniper team supporting to assault
teams
for hits every single night so my job
specifically was containment
so setting and establishing containment
a lot of building climbing that rotation
um a lot of overwatch killing squirters
running out of buildings
uh killing bad guys trying to get to the
fight and
it was like the gloves are off i mean
the strategy that we got
passed down in rules of engagement were
um
kill them all i mean that's what that's
what we were doing and so it was a it
was an epic
rotation we had a lot of hvts a lot of
foreign fighters
a lot of gunfights um a lot of
casualties
on on our side and
a lot of dead bad guys were you guys
mostly taking vehicles were you doing
helicopters all the time
most of it was halfs with helicopter
assaults with little birds
and uh and mh-60s so all blackhawks and
little birds
every i think pretty much every night it
was that i don't remember too many
ground assaults a couple here and there
in strikers if we had to go to sauder
city we took
tanks that would lead the way into
sauder city
suck up all the efps we call them team
rock
they would get blown up for us even to
the point blossom yeah even to the point
where these guys would get blown up
they'd pull over the side of the road
and we'd just bypass
they were just a breach point and uh
they were the hammer
we were going through and hitting our
surgical targets and
it was a great rotation man we we lost a
guy
one of our uh team guys uh justin monsky
was killed
stepped on a pressure plate id we had
about uh
in my company we had about 15 purple
hearts so a lot of dudes injured shot
blown up
um and a lot we killed a lot of bad guys
i mean it was a good trip for killing
bad guys
how are these um your what what's your
position as far as leadership inside
the company here so i'm uh i'm a two ic
so i'm right behind my cell leader um as
a new sniper
um so i do what my cell leader at the
time jason
tells me to do and most of my role
is because i was pretty lean and a good
climber
me and a couple of the other guys were
in the climbing team and so if we had a
containment set we hit a building
we used ladders or even building climb
traverse ladders
um from building to building and set
containment from a high position
called high team to be able to contain
the objective from top
down while the assaulters hit a
deliberate target set so
traditional countdowns five four three
two breach goes off at two and then and
we hit the target
and you're doing an open night basically
sometimes
the other yeah sometimes a couple more
than that yeah we a lot of this
this time period was taking advantage of
ssc there was an emphasis on sensitive
site exploitation
doing a lot of post analysis on the
objective a lot of tactical
interrogation
to lend itself to taking advantage of
the opportunity on a target
and flexing to other targets to take
down networks
so super aggressive you know the
combination of tutu
uh sas ranger battalion uh kag us
and dev uh five action arms under task
416. and this is stanley mcchrystal's
big project right his his um
his big uh machine of war what
what it was was one of the most
significant i think
most significant strategies in the war
especially of attrition of taking out
bad guys
as you're you talked about um you're
losing some guys now
how's how's your um
how are you guys handling that so the
reason i asked this
question is because somebody's going to
be listening to this in 10 years or 17
years or 23 years
and we're going to be in a situation
where there hasn't been any casualties
in a long time and
all of a sudden someone's going out and
doing what
doing what soldiers do and they're going
to take casualties and i know
when i when i took my first casualties
and had lost my first guys there was
no one that was telling me like hey
here's what you've got to think about
not just from a look we get the protocol
of hey here's the here's the book that
we're gonna follow here's the
calls we gotta make but now you got a
bunch of guys that just lost one of
their best friends and
what are you gonna do about that
how did you guys go about it great
question
um a lot of responses
that are um doctrinal
would have guys stand down have a
moments if not days of mourning a
process
i remember when we lost tongue uh in 06
our immediate strategy at the tactical
level so
you're talking cell leaders and troops
aren't majors
said listen we're not waiting we're
hitting targets tonight
and we got aggressive and we went out
um and in 06 and 07 we had
a vindiction vindication board
this vindication board was uh filled
with team guys that we lost
and there was dozens of them on one side
and when you killed a bad guy because
you took that call sign patch
and then you know if it was tony yoast
who was a third group team sergeant i
was killed
you would carry t-y on your left
shoulder under your call sign patch
and if you killed a bad guy and you were
successful in your mission you'd come
back
and you put it on the vindicated side
and
we had all the pictures of the guys that
were killed on that and every night
we'd fill that board and cycle them back
and forth
because we understood that
getting killed was a part of the job
comparatively
and and you know this you're very
schooled in this history of
of warfare including the vietnam war
where
thousands 60 plus thousand americans
were killed sometimes hundreds in
certain battles
were killed entire mack v sog teams
taken off the planet
they accepted that risk so when we lost
guys in our community
there was no warning there wasn't time
no more we get back on helicopters
i remember um something that really
stands out to me from the 07 trip
we lost two two sas guys they were
killed
on target and there was two or three of
them that were killed
the task force commander had us come
outside and the 2-2 sas commander
briefed five different task units
and he spoke to warfare and he spoke to
the importance
of understanding the fight we're in how
this works
and getting back in the fight it was a
10 minute spill
and we're all sitting there in kit with
guns in our specific units
and at the end of the speech he gives a
hand in arm signal and all the little
birds and all the 60s spin up
and we load five different task forces
up in little birds and m860s and fly
away
and smash bad guys that whole experience
was what the task force was depending on
what unit you were
you might have that experience but if
you're on task force that was the
experience every night
we accepted that risk we lost guys and
then we got back in the fight because we
had no time to mourn
it wasn't a time for morning
that's um same strategy i had
yeah got to get your [ __ ] back on get
your gear back on
and go back out and um do what you're
supposed to do yeah and do what your
boys would want you to do
exactly yeah
any good leadership lessons or any
leadership lessons from that deployment
that stand out
the biggest one is i'll say his name now
because he's retired
um he was the commander that we worked
under his name was tom detomaso
he was a platoon leader in blackhawk
down as a young ranger
at the time was a kag commander
and he was our commander when we got to
that country
we had gotten used to the way that we
did business
breaching blowing every door shooting
bad guys in the face
and he briefed us and he said man we're
going to start this new tactic this year
and it's called call outs and we laughed
we joked it was comical to us we even we
even wrote
drew cartoons about how comical this
whole tactic was
so let me get this straight you want us
to go to a building land little birds
offset
surreptitiously approach and then knock
essentially knock and call them out yes
that's that's what we want you to do
so the whole time we're like this is
ridiculous this is insane
until we hit a foreign safe house that
had libyan foreign fighters
and in the war in iraq positions two
and four out of the top four guys killed
on the battlefield that were killing
americans
formidable foes were from libya two and
four
number one was saudi arabia number two
was um libya
out of these uh foreign fighters uh they
were training in the green mountains of
libya
they had gear that was comparable to
ours a solo boots
suntow watches chess rigs suicide vests
proper guns with a red dot optics
and all the tactics to bear we hit a
foreign safe house
offset on infill which was a about a 4k
2-4k offset which is offsetting away
from the objective so you don't get
compromised
we get compromised by a early warning
position
our little bird attack helicopter kills
six dudes right off the bat
on infill birds get straight the bird
i'm in the 60 i'm in
feet hanging off the 60 takes incoming
rounds
um in between us and the chalk in front
of us
we land we make movement we think
there's a couple foreign fighters
there's 13
and they're all suicide invested out um
you know long story short i have a dog
saved my life uh
a cag dog by the name of vinnie been a
suicide bomber 15 meters in front of me
um sacrifice his life for mine we get
into the house
we kill everybody we establish
um ssc after objective secure
and realize they have pkm machine guns
barricaded
and positions a threshold deep
away from the reach point if we'd have
breached that like every target set we
breached
prior we would all die we would have got
the first assault element would have
been zipped up
they would have broke contacted out of
back and we've been fighting for our
lives
we were fighting for our lives and
containment we had offset containment
called them out and we were in a
hand-to-hand
um uh range so you did end up doing
containment and doing a call out on them
we did
yeah we did we did exactly what he
trained us to do
and even in that i mean i threw six hand
grenades
on the other side of a berm in direct
engagement in contact with the enemy
i mean the hand grenades i was throwing
with my teammate were landing in bad
guys laps on the other side of the berm
these dudes were ready to get it on we
decimated the target with 105s from a
spectre gunship
we recovered vinnie's body and then
we dropped a a j dam on it on xvil in
daylight
and we got back you know uh vinnie was
covered in an american flag
the whole task force there was uh there
to salute us
and we're you know we got blood on our
shoes uh
some dudes are injured and we're like
this makes sense and i realized
from that experience don't be in a rush
to die
so many guys want to get on the x and
they want to do this thing
called kicking indoors and shoot bags in
the face
but they don't understand the tactics
and techniques
procedures evolve every single day at
the speed of war
and it was the realization where i had
the coolest guy
because he's the coolest commander of
the coolest unit telling us
something that didn't seem cool and then
that realization coming home and going
damn okay now we gotta change tactics we
gotta think outside the box
we can't get uh we can't conform to
convention and to routine
and think it's going to be the right
solution every single time because times
change
and that was a huge impact on my career
moving forward
yeah i went through a similar transition
in 0304
where we were breaching every door and
um we ended up hurting some some people
you know and sometimes not the right
people
and we started getting some pressure
like hey you can't just keep doing this
and so well if you're not going to
explosively breach then that leaves you
mechanically breaching if you're
mechanically breaching well now you're
sitting there with the huli
swinging at the door and now you're
really exposed
so why not just take a step back and say
hey get the terp on the horn and and
tell these guys to come out
and now we kind of know what we're
dealing with and and yeah
as you can imagine um the pushback i got
was was you know pretty strong from from
the guys
because they're thinking we're giving up
this tactical advantage we should
explosively breach every time and
and i was getting pressure from my boss
and what i realized is if it makes sense
to explosively breach
awesome we will do it and i told my boss
if it makes sense for us to explosively
breach
we're gonna do it and if we don't need
to we won't and if we call out as
appropriate we'll call it as appropriate
so right there's
three courses of action which for the
first few months i was there there was
one course of action
and how long does it take the enemy to
figure that out and and like you're
saying by what was this now this is oh
seven of course they'd figured out oh we
can put a barricaded
sandbagged position two rooms deep you
know
on the main breach point and we'll have
a field day yeah
yeah it was their their mo i mean look
guys uh often think about warfare
and they think the opposing side is
are these shadows and these entities and
these paper targets these are creative
human beings
who aren't conformed to convention they
don't have
doctrinal time hacks and requirements
that they have to abide by
they wake up they use their imagination
and sometimes that imagination trumps
the fighting force conventional
uh tactic that you bring to bear and you
gotta adapt you gotta be malleable
yeah i mean even the idea of what we
ended up calling combat clearance and i
don't know if you guys called the combat
clearance but like hey we're gonna open
the door and we're gonna look
like hey i'm not why would i run in
there yeah and are there times we gotta
run in there absolutely we're getting
shot at in the hallway i'm gonna get
into this room we're getting shot out in
the street we're gonna bust the store
we're gonna get in this building that's
what's gonna happen
but if we're safe in the street and it's
secure and we open this door or we
breach the store
what are we running in for there what
are we running in why would we do that
so again that was another thing that was
contrary to everything that
not everything i had learned but to the
bulk of what i had learned
which is hey speed violence of action
like we're gonna get when that door
opens we're going in and i get it
there's plenty of times where that's the
appropriate behavior
absolutely there's also times where
that's not the appropriate behavior
and it's difficult to overcome what you
always i always feel like what you look
what the first thing you learned is what
you kind of
um you prefer right whatever you learn
first whatever methodology you learn
when you're a new guy
you think that's the way it is and it
can be hard to overcome that barrier
there's a bias there's a there's an
actual bias around that
i forget what the name of the bias but
there's a cognitive bias around whatever
oh anchoring
so whatever you learn first whatever
piece of information you get first
that's kind of what you anchor to yeah
so it can be difficult to overcome and
say hey wait a second does this really
make sense
and believe me i mean i i met that stiff
resistance with a lot of guys along the
way
and and what i tried not to do was be
like you don't know or
this doesn't i'd be like okay well let's
talk through it you know and actually
i'll tell you what let's break out some
ammunition and let's give it a shot
why don't you show me how it works out
when you go rushing into this room
when you don't know what's in there and
there's no reason to rush in there look
if you're getting shot out in the
hallway i get it
but if you're not man what are we doing
yeah yeah don't be in a rush to die yeah
uh so that was a freaking savage
deployment then it was
it was epic and once again what's you
you knew it at the time i mean every
time every night you're loading up birds
going
you're this is as good as it's ever
going to get yeah i
i had multiple conversations with guys
in the team room in the kit room
getting loaded out like it doesn't get
any better than this guys remember
every single moment of this because
you'll never get this again how old were
you
26 7 now but that's you so that's your
third deployment though so you knew it
yeah
yeah and you got to relish in it i was
comfortable in war that was
that was i was getting i was
fixing mistakes i was making
and honing this craft and i was getting
pretty good at it and you know there was
opportunities
inside of my unit to do whatever i
wanted to do
and i took all those opportunities and
it was
it was a great playing field for
creativity and we we did a lot of cool
stuff man it was it was amazing it was
uh
that task force crystal's task force
um was awesome um colonel or sergeant
major command sergeant major nacie
was the unit major at the time and uh
i remember we had a team patch and a
brief and
our team patch had some
skulls on it and it was like one of
those you know
badass like punisher skull deals right
and i'm thinking sarmade or nace is
going to see this and he's going to be
pissed so during a brief we're doing a
brief right before we load helicopters
and he looks at it
and i see him side eye one of the
patches
and the patch says kill them all on the
patch
and he kind of side eyes it and i'm like
oh [ __ ]
and i go to uh my cell then i'm like
jason dude he's side in that patch we're
screwed
and this is the unit sergeant major and
so um
he he comes over and uh he says hey
who's whose patches are these
and jason steps forward and he pulls
them in the hall they come with me
and he goes um let me see that patch and
he pulls it off his shoulder and i see
this go down in the hallway i'm like oh
dude
this dude is like jason's going home
like we're not doing this hop
and he hands in the patch and
sergeant major reaches inside of his
pocket and pulls out
a handful of jsoc coins that's a
task force and has all the numbers it's
a skull
on the back side it says uh something
like operating at the speed of war
and he hands him the coins he goes this
is the coolest patch i've ever seen
and he slaps it on his arm and he walks
out i'm like
that did not go the way i thought i was
gonna go i was like we're in the right
place
this is this is where it's at right now
yeah and um
this is where this is where
you lose people i mean mentally you lose
people
yeah because
if you're not if you if you if you don't
know what we're talking about
if this sounds like uh hyper aggressive
or crazy or whatever
what you're forgetting is that the whole
object of war is to kill the bad guys
that's the that's what we're doing
that's the purpose
i remember i heard a story they were you
know i read some news story
and it was i think it was a marine unit
and they were talking about the fact
that this marine unit
had um like a scoreboard on the wall
of number of bad guys killed and each
one of them was like a k bar like a
little k bar was drawn up there
and the tone of this article was
you know just just disturbed by this uh
can you believe that this
u.s marine corps unit and i think it's a
marine corps unit who had these
you know was keeping score of the number
of enemy that they killed and proudly
displayed a k-bar knife
and i was just thinking man what how
what do you think we're doing over there
yeah what do you think we're doing over
there now where you got to be careful is
is well for one thing you got to be
careful because you got you got to
protect your guys
and if you get them in that mindset they
can go too far with it of course
you've also got to be careful because
you're not building good
relations with civilians or
reporters or the public
at least part of the public because part
of the public goes what are you doing
what do you mean kill them all
so it's a it's a touchy thing it's a
touchy subject
and yet the the entire purpose of a
military unit
is to kill the bad guys and man i said
this the other day somewhere and people
were like
freaking out about it and and i'm like
well no i mean i understand you've got
supply people
but one of those supply people supplying
they're supplying
bullets so that the front line guys what
about the people that are
you know collecting intelligence well
they're collecting intelligence so the
frontline guys can go kill people like
everyone that's what we're here for
that's what we're here for there's no
other thing and sure are there
humanitarian missions yes
are we gonna try and win hearts and
minds yes all those things
all those things are secondary the fact
that a military
is to kill bad guys are they here to
protect and defend yes absolutely
how do they protect and defend kill bad
guys that's it
so you wrap up that deployment wrap up
that deployment and then um
start doing advanced training i mean i i
have a lot of catching up to do so
um because you've done four back to back
to back deployments
yes yeah in every break every month or
every day of break is
get get more honed you know like you
need to get more trained
um i think that year in between those
rotations
i went to sniper school i went to free
fall school
i went to jtac school um all to
again become an asset more of an asset
on my team so i went to special forces
snipers
course um how long is the special forces
sniper school
uh a couple months it's pretty long i
think it's uh two and a half months
a little bit of technical a lot of
tactical a lot of long gun
um but it's evolved over time um rangers
go to that same school
cag snipers go to that same school and
special forces snipers go to that school
as well
um great experience learned a lot
i think out of those out of that break
what i learned most
was the difficulty of close air support
i was one of the few guys that got
picked up and tasked to go to the school
and i'm like i'm going to sotac with
sotac
especially operations terminal air
control school i'm like dude i don't
want to go to sotech
like look if you're a sniper and you're
doing sniper operations
you want to keep the team small so
somebody has to have that skill set so
you can drop bombs i'm like
well that makes sense all right does
that mean i'm tethered to a radio
likely but it means you'll kill more bad
guys i'm all about that
so they sent me to one of the most
difficult schools i've been to a sotac
by the way
how long is that school uh a few weeks i
think three weeks it's a couple weeks of
uh ground
and then an air week where you call live
fire and uh
all different aircrafts and platforms
only school i've almost failed
really i i was blatant about it
the technical aspects of speaking big
art big military language
like lat long i mean i i could speak
mgrs in braille like i'm good at mcrs
but then they said lat long and i'm like
what the hell is lat long
so so the air force controllers that i
went to they're like
you don't know what lat law i'm like
dude i've never even heard the term
like what's lat long like i have to
learn this like it's all that long
because you have to communicate to the
aviators
and they speak that long i'm like oh no
and so i was you know doing the homework
late at night
i was a senior e7 i was a class leader
and i was blade running
i almost failed that course so i was
this close
and i think the air force dudes there
they didn't want to see me
uh pass they they were a little stoked
they're like oh this senior sf guy
this dude's all he's blade running damn
savages bro yeah they wanted to see me
fail out i passed though and i got my
air uh close air support uh
certification
and then i rotated back into 08 another
war
and what are you doing this last this
last time in oh wait so 08 um
i was a troop advisor for the ictf
the iraqi counterterrorism force was
born and bred
by the sif companies a15 and b23
uh fifth group um sif and third groups
pulled these guys
into jordan isolated and trained them
and then
infiltrated back into the country
smashing bad guys
and the ictf the young operators of the
ictf
they don't get breaks they don't get a
uh
a red cycle right they they stay in
warfare
and they through the culminative years
of war
got the most experience and were some of
the most experienced operators i've ever
served with
so i advised the whole troop and at the
time we were downsizing american forces
so me a navy eod guy a camo guy
maybe a combo guy and then a troop full
of icts spanking targets
so what time of in 2008 were you there
the entire summer so probably march
april time frame
until you know six months into it almost
to christmas
yeah and this is smashing targets
all all by we are calling them true
bilateral operations right and we're
trying to work ourselves out of a job
a lot of guys were bummed out by it um
things were getting political
in no way i was signing shooter
statements if i was admitting that i was
killing bad guys which we start
stopped doing i mean we stopped
admitting we were killing bad guys
because
at that time if you killed a guy he
wrote a shooter statement and it went to
the doj
in iraq i actually remember one time
i came back from an op and my commander
my company commander comes to me goes
hey mike you're good to go back out on
ops i was like
i just got back from a knob sir what are
you talking about
oh you're being investigated for that
last shooting yet i'm like
what what do you mean investigated like
well yeah they had to do a trial process
and they took it to trial they did the
shooter statement with witnesses and
everything else and then you're good i'm
like
what i went to my teamster i'm like dude
what is going on they're
we're going on trial and and through
paperwork and then
we're shut down from operations he's
like yeah just it's part of the climate
i'm like
uh and it's it's it's one of the first
times in
in in leading because i was leading a
troop an entire troop of ictf
that i started getting affected by the
political climate all the other times
i've been insulated
by cell leaders team sergeants good
leadership who knew
that they just keep all that [ __ ] away
from the
guys and let them do their job and it's
the first time it started trickling down
and i'm like
oh oh wow yeah yeah i was thinking about
that when you're talking about your 07
deployment i mean your
le your focus was 100
on your job that's it and so people
above you in the chain of command and
that's a huge
that was a superlative supportive
chain of command as well yeah and so you
weren't dealing with any of this other
crap now all of a sudden you show up in
08 and you find out you're under
investigation super political
yeah super political so did you uh
you you just kept doing ops backed off a
little bit did you back off a little bit
or just
so the ops weren't as aggressive like i
remember telling my new guys because i
was a cell leader at the time and a
tripadvisor
i remember telling my new sif guys bro
it's about to be on
get your stuff ready bring the thumper
plenty of fork before
mike we're about to kill some bad guys
and going and we went to sadder city
and it was crickets and i'm like this
isn't normal i was like dude it's going
to happen we're going to get ambushed
efps nothing and i'm like what is go
we got back i'm like that that was
probably just random
we're going to get back into it and
we're going to go kill and they then we
get went
out again and i'm like there's nothing
happening what is going on
and because of the um at the times
the sunnis and the shias were doing a
ceasefire
and any time they killed americans they
would pay for it politically
they started pulling back and just just
isolating
building their uh their infrastructure
in their castles
and not do not being aggressive but all
the things that we were hitting were dry
holes
we we got in a few gunfights killed a
few dudes
but it was it was not what i expected it
to be and it was the transition of
what became i think the transition out
of that other
that fight yeah i know when um one of my
buddies
took over my task unit and went into
solder city with snipers
in i want to say it was uh june of 08
yeah and they
killed all kinds of bad guys and they
did about
four to six weeks of operations there
and the freaking um
uh the shakes they're kind of like all
right we're good we're we're good
we don't we don't need any more of this
yeah and they
made that truce and stuff yeah um and
you know the way i looked at it was like
they'd been doing operations for so long
like the the
the the moddy army and stuff out of
sauder city
and they would take so few casualties
yeah i mean they go out
set off in the fp and kill an american
or two or
what you know go lob and like i said
they don't really have to they don't
have to win every time like it doesn't
matter they're going to go back and
they'll attack again tomorrow night or
the next night
and uh but then once they started taking
some massive casualties
yeah like i think we've had enough for
this yeah it was pretty bad i remember
that time period
um so i was a sniper at the time so in
between
my troop being up i did stay behind
sniper operations
and we actually took from what i
understand we took one of the missions
that you guys had
you guys were doing daylight overwatch
for the guys who were building the tea
barriers around sauder city and you guys
killed a whole bunch of people
when we came in they switched it to
night ops
and we couldn't kill anybody like i sat
on a rooftop for like days and weeks
going
where the hell are the bad guys and guys
were talking like the navy killed them
all
like where are they they're like they're
not coming out they all gave up their
if once you did reverse ops uh that
tactic worked because
they were getting smoked in daylight and
so and i think chris kyle at one point
had that up yeah
and um so i remember we remember hearing
about his name and some of the guys and
like oh dude they have a high body count
we were so excited
and we infilled day one it was like
crickets and i'm like what is
and they had a they had a drone i
remember seeing a drone overhead
and they were low flying this drone
during the building of this wall
and the completion of it i'm like no
wonder there's no bad like all the bad
guys hear this drone on purpose
as a tactic that we applied but they're
all keeping their head down
and we couldn't kill any of them and i
was like oh this sucks but the stay
behind stuff was fun
yeah the that that was a big kind of a
when i was in ramada it's the same thing
like the bad guys were they knew not to
come out at night now yeah
90 whatever probably 97 of the bad guys
that got killed by my task in it were in
the daytime
yeah the other three percent were at
night because they knew if they came out
at night it was a bad deal for them
so they came out in the day and it's the
same thing that those guys did in sadr
city
um
that's another so it's another
deployment another six months this six
months yeah
and it's going out hitting targets but
it's definitely more mellow on this
deployment
yeah it was more of a a leadership role
in troop advising the server major
because i was acting as the ground force
commander for every op
so i l i started learning a lot about
processes
you know like before i was just in a nug
assaulter i was called a ghost assaulter
just there
doing my little narrow piece of the pie
now i had to step back
and get the big picture i had to control
air assets i had to
flex to different targets i had to
strategize on the fly
with my troops major deploying his
troops and
we had a whole bunch of incidents like
where you know
me and the eod guy the navy eod guy are
hitting targets by ourself
because they're hitting a building we
get intel i don't have enough time to
flex that whole troop
we have to do it so we go inside of
houses by ourself
and it was fun man we had a blast it was
like it was cool because we had the
leash off
and even though it wasn't as active i
mean we were doing i remember we had an
intel from a soccer field
that they had a couple handsets that
correlated to the soccer field and i was
like
all right we got to get the soccer field
so i said hey guys we're going to move
to the soccer field
so we started walking i'm like i need
you guys to move out and they wouldn't
move out
i grabbed the eod guy we sprinted to the
soccer field
as we ran around the block that we were
an ambient street light
the group of guys were meeting and they
were in the middle of soccer field the
middle of night like two in the morning
they see us and we're sprinting across
an open field
trying to shoot like 10 dudes who move
in 10 different directions
and we miss everybody and and when we
get back the uh
everybody in the jock and the talk is
laughing because they're like dude
that was the best [ __ ] we've ever seen
because we saw you guys break contact
from the main element and you're like
screw it and you start sprinting but
they all went 10 different directions so
we couldn't track any of them and we're
running and shooting
and we're standing there in the field
like damn it that was our opportunity
it was good times man uh
wrap up that deployment then what's next
so i i
i get back and i go to kag and i'm in
kag in a
a techno curl reconnaissance role and i
go back to iraq and tip to blot
and i only i i run because of my
reconnaissance background
is how i got recruited in i run a joint
interagency task force
of um interagency organizations with
jsoc
to do reconnaissance over the entire
country of iraq
um i was i was undercover as a
lieutenant colonel so i was an oic
young oic nobody believed it
but put it in that position to see to
and control
all the things that were going on for
reconnaissance assets in the country
now in balad at that time period because
everything was uh
downsizing including the base of blood
what year is this now oh nine
yeah so stuff's really slowing down
really slowing down in fact
the reason they brought me in is because
reconnaissance
is obviously another way we get involved
without involving packs on the ground
people on the ground
so we still had to have a have eyes on
but we had to use technical means of
reconnaissance and not just depend on
dudes and hide sites
in fact during that time period there
was a restriction of one or two
americans per
target and you had to stay in
containment so if you're moving to a bad
guy place
you leave behind the americans they'd
stay on containment with the vehicles
um indigenous force would hit the
objective come back
and then you'd roll out and so at that
time working in the joint interagency
i didn't feel like i was missing out on
much i felt like i had a broader role to
fill
in that in that capacity and then and
you're just overseeing all this
reconnaissance elements that's what
you're saying all of it i
i had daily vtcs with
uh still team command navsoff
mostly which was the main effort by the
way there wasn't a lot of sf guys in the
country
at that time so i had daily vtcs with
the navy
and supported their operations and
technical reconnaissance means
tagging tracking locating all the all
the sexy stuff for uh technical recon
um for the entire country and that was
based on the fact that you had
sniper experience yeah i got recruited
experience or whatever yeah i got
recruited i went to selection all
successful and then
um my background my entire life my
background in special operations was
mapped for that that feel of expertise
uh in the transition
coming back from oa till nine i went to
jay sock's uh
technical reconnaissance course which
was like six months a pretty intense
course
and learned a whole new world of
of operations that i didn't even know
existed i know a little bit
but when i went to that course i was
like whoa now this is this is some cool
[ __ ]
so i i did that for task force for jsoc
for my 09 rotation and then what
happened after that
um gap back and then got with another
squadron and at that time we hadn't been
in iraq
uh since we killed zarqawi the task
force hasn't been in iraq um really
since
i mean intermittently um we we owned
iraq
but afghanistan we completely gave up so
our eye wasn't
uh on the ball in afghanistan because we
were too busy in iraq
and then all of a sudden we had a change
of heart
like al qaeda was on the run we didn't
even know this thing called isis existed
and we decided to do a surge as an
organization
to afghanistan and i was on the first
thing smoking
so my first real
good deployment with that organization
with a special emissions unit
was in afghanistan and when we got there
um the rangers on the battle space
colonel carrillo was in charge and we
were the
red-headed stepchildren and i was like
what how's in smu the stepchildren like
when i got there
i was taking showers with bottles of
water in an open field and i'm like
this is the premier ct unit on the
planet and i'm doing this and like dude
we have to we're building everything
from scratch so we set up shop there
and started targeting bad guys and it
the first two months was prep and then
the second two months was killing bad
guys
um and we did a lot of it that that that
second 60 days of that four-month
rotation
we i saw more bad guys killed in a
two-month period than
anything that i experienced before and
it was because of the assets that we
brought to bear
um good rotation though and you were you
were still overseeing recce
at this point yeah i was i was that
squadron's
reconnaissance nco which just
specialized in recon
so everything from ops to technical
recce
to uh um interagency like even
controlling aircraft
for for isr and
it was an active trip i mean we lost a
dog we had guys shot we had guys blown
up
um a lot of active operations during
that period of time
it was it was amazing to see the talent
and you can't really get an idea or
understanding of that talent and
capability
when you when you focus on individuals
but when you see it come together in
a single combat operation where
everybody's so efficient and effective
you really see the benefit of the
selection process the training process
and the support mechanisms that make
that unit
the the most elite unit in the world
yeah you know you hear like the um
sports analogies
of like well you know it's like a
professional sports team but
these are like that the champions right
these are the nfl
freaking super bowl winners that you
know that you see the super bowl guy
that like um
whatever gets his right arm massaged
so that he can whatever and he and this
other guy's doing speed drills with
the first four meters of his sprint and
he's going to work with a specialist
that's going to get him
even a little bit you know one
millisecond faster and then they're
getting their helmets dialed in so that
they can have calms in there
and they got this you know they get all
like this 100
pure focus for every individual to be as
good as they possibly can and then you
put that team together and every one of
those individuals is 100
focused on being as good as they
possibly can with all the support they
could possibly want
and that's what you end up with just
just freaking the best
yeah it's the big leagues for sure and i
what i realized in that unit even
being a very competent shooter a
respected member of
um special forces and um
being a pt stud at the time that
um there was men above me and beyond me
that i'd never catch up with
that were just so talented and i was
like it was humbling
and i'm like well i'm not the most elite
dude i thought i was
i woke up and went dude i'm crushing it
and then i see the talent pool over
there
and realized um there's this thing this
machine
and like you said before um these guys
aren't trained to be diplomats to be fit
experts
they're trying to kill bad guys and
they're the best at it
i mean the navy version and the army
version they're the best at it
in the world and it was a humbling and
honorable experience of being part of
that
so what came after that so at a very
young age
actually at the age of 29 i made e8
how's your wife handling all this by the
way she's good she's a champ at the time
i don't she's not married to me now
um so it didn't last but she's handling
it well man i mean i mean
look she her her perspective was if i
was
happy doing what i loved uh that was my
moment in time
and she would support me um do you have
any kids no kids
no kids none so it was easy for us right
she was busy getting her nursing degree
phenomenal woman um just just handling
business
and grinding and then when i came back
she was
my support and make sure made sure
because you knew i was coming back and
in that unit especially
those those boys don't have any downtime
it doesn't exist
even when you're down you're not down
you're up on a
a call cycle for being able to quick
respond
or you're in a down cycle and you're
training you're always gone i was gone
more
than any part of my career in that
organization
so um when i made
the e8 list i made it on the black side
there's the blacklist
and the blacklist is just it's not
advertised
and i was the just to give i don't know
the exact numbers but
for that year it was something like 160
guys were promoted
i was 159.7 on the blacklist because the
blacklist like you're like a
intermittent number that's not
advertised i was the last guy
on the black side which includes the
navy that was promoted to e8
which means i was the last guy to get
picked up and i was 29 years old
i was an e8 as an e8 yeah and so
i i you know i it was mainly because of
the combat experience i had
and then in e7 school which is for us
it's called a knock i won the leadership
award
and so those two things set me up to get
promoted that fast but i wasn't prepared
in my operational career to go you're an
e8
what's next so if i stayed in that unit
then i would have just been what i was
you know um
in that unit you're not
what's called blue chips you don't get
blue chips because uh you have
experience you could be a 20-year
special operations guy
when you show up to that unit day one
you earn your blue chips one day at a
time
and so me starting i was starting
starting from zero leaving the unit
and going anywhere i could have gone i'm
a team sergeant
i'm a god in the in the special
operations right
and it's the job that you want because
you're controlling
and and operating with your oda with
your detachment
i had no look i wanted to go back but i
was like
if i go back they'll put me on a regular
oda
and not meaning that in a derogatory way
but just not a sif company not a
specialized company
randomly a gentleman by the name of
command sergeant major bob irby
who's a legend in social forces command
communicates to me
that he heard i heard i made e8 and he
heard about my experience
and he wanted to recruit me to stand up
a new cariff a new a new commander's
response force
for the the continent of africa
we didn't have one because we were so
busy fighting in the middle east we
didn't have one
jay sock approved that and long story
short
i stood up a sif as a plank holder from
scratch
we went into a company in 10th group me
and another guy from the unit
stood it up from scratch had full power
to train anything we wanted to with our
guys uh reconnaissance guys
and build this unit from zero uh as we
built the unit we got
vetted and validated and then benghazi
kicked off which
by our benefit winded up being in africa
so
did you deploy immediately i deployed
immediately i was the first team to
deploy for that unit
to benghazi to libya this is after the
september
12th attacks yeah september 11 and 12
attacks
in 12th in 2012. um
during our train up we literally get
tasked to go to libya we start
developing intel and then benghazi kicks
off
and when that happened i was actually in
a special missions unit compound doing
cross kle briefs
with libya and then this thing happens
and then um a few weeks later i'm in
tripoli libya
going building out a counterterrorism
force going after
uh abu qatada the guy responsible for it
did you run it we didn't run any of
those ops though did we
so um one
we didn't do anything about it right it
was a big 13 hours in benghazi is
kind of reflective of that understanding
but we had the opportunity to kill abu
katala
in about 60 to 90 days uh there are
other use of sock elements with us
and they positively identify that dude
in a short period of time
i was there in the meeting when we
proposed it to the country team
which included the ambassador char jay
alexander pope
who was appointed and he denied it he
said the political climate won't allow
us to do this
the representative from yousuf senior e8
stood up and almost detonated i mean he
detonated
in a very tactful way um but that was
the climate we were dealing with
it was it was so politically charged
they wouldn't allow us to do anything
for six months i was in that country
fighting to kill bad guys
to do our job as the commander's
response force but also representing
yusuf
and they wouldn't let us do anything it
was horrible it was
it was the worst political military
experience that
that i faced
so what'd you do when you got home from
that that had to leave a bad taste in
your mouth
well it did uh three weeks after i got
back i was out of the army
i dropped my paperwork as a senior e8
with how many years in
at the time 16 16 years
when i was downrange i got recruited by
the cia
and i was going to take a job called
paramilitary operations officer which is
a
you can go on us or cia.gov and apply
for it um
job description there yeah yeah mike
spann was one of the first
casualties of the global war on terror
on september 11th and um he was actually
a paramilitary operations officer i
wanted to be mike's man
i had i had just finished my college
degree which took me 15 years to
accomplish
which is a prerequisite for government
service and federal federal government
and i decided at that point i wanted to
step aside
and work for this agency because i saw
the good things they were doing
at the time after i got back and out
processed very rapidly where people were
like
my troop and my my the main element
wasn't even
home yet and i was already out processed
my independence was july 4th of that
year
of 2013 and immediately started
contracting went straight back to libya
i was in libya on terminal leave back in
libya as a civilian
and then uh started contracting with the
agency
uh for the la for the next two and a
half years while at the same time
in a reserve component of special
operations
um and where i was a team sergeant in
texas
then made sergeant major in texas and so
i was
contracting deploying with interagency
coming home
and then deploying again deploying again
yeah
put on my uniform jump on a plane
i mean one time i came back from yemen a
week later i was back in nazir africa
with a serpent major uniform on doing a
counter-terrorism staff operation
or staff exercise that turned into an
operation came back
put on my civilians and then went back
to yemen so i was just in a
cycle of it give us a little bit of a
brief on what you're doing as a
what your job was as a contractor so
honestly
um it's nothing sexy uh i was
babysitting case officers i mean my job
was to protect him overseas
um i was outside of the what people
would
uh normally refer to as industrial
contractors so i actually work directly
for
the agency and and babysat case officers
and protected them um when you're a case
officer and you come out of school
uh you got a 500 pound head lots of
experience
in training but it's all concepts
when they go overseas we only have
enough time to repair
the biggest and brightest minds on the
planet
to do what they do and so we we are the
um the shield that protects these guys
to do their job
and at the time that i applied you had a
minimum experience of six years in
special operations
and you had to shoot your ass off and i
when i showed up for this job i vetted
it's a shooting call you shoot and you
meet the standard
or you leave my class we had probably 10
10 dudes
that are senior level dudes operators in
the most elite units
half of them probably went home because
the shooting calls you're competing for
a six-figure job
also so the pressure is high and the
shooting standards are the
the hardest shooting standards i've seen
apparently in federal government because
you're
a federal law enforcement instructor
after you get through this experience
it's the toughest federal law
enforcement call that's informal it's
not
actually doctrine and
when i went down range with that
organization
i was confident that even me and my
writing partner
typically were seals that with our
little glock 17 pea shooters and a
waistband that we could do some work
uh enough to fight back to our vehicle
or back to the machine gun in our
vehicle
um and do some work but it also taught
me about uh
what these interagencies and these brave
men and women do every day
which is they put it on the line like
you don't have a
qrf uh ranger battalion element
in mh-47s prepared to come rescue your
ass
it's just you and i'm like dude you guys
do this like yeah we've been doing this
since the beginning like what
just driving around randomly doing your
thing and like that's all
like what what's the nearest task force
oh they're about three hours away
like okay so we're out on our own that
changed everything for me
i mean that's that that changed
everything i thought
in uh that i potentially knew about
singleton operations and low vis
operations we think love is
our guys thought low vis was like
putting a chimaga on
you know and hiding their chest carrier
or play carrier underneath their
their dress their man dress it's not
it's it's a
it's a new game it was crazy you you do
that for two and a half years
two and a half years yeah and did you so
you you
originally wanted to actually be in the
cia not a contractor
you did were you continuing to try and
pursue the job of actually being
a member yeah i wanted to be a staffer i
wanted to be a blue badger i wanted to
be a full-time employee
and i had a change of heart when i was
in yemen
yemen was super political the houthis
the political climate
all these things that were transpiring
was
doing what i didn't think was possible
in that interagency
which was um debilitating their ability
to do their job
and i saw great guys that were on
operational side on the operational side
that were getting uh um stagnated
and i i couldn't believe it
i actually i remember thinking to myself
on one rotation
wait this doesn't happen to these guys
there's there's no way these dudes
there's no way these guys are getting
there's got to be something going on
cloak and dagger and it wasn't
because uh the oversight of how the
interagency the ic works
in the intelligence community with well
over 17 agencies now
there's so much direct uh directorate
national level oversight and
micromanagement
they can't do their jobs and so i had my
whole thing with getting on the military
was
if i can't kill bad guys i don't belong
here so i left
because i went to an organization which
i thought were still killing bad guys
and they still were in some capacity but
where i was
in the situation i was in they weren't
and i went dude
i have to make i have to have a change
of heart here i have to figure something
out
because the war for me is over there's
no more killing
i mean eventually isis popped their
heads up
and there was a whole new cycle of
killing that i missed which i i wish i
was part of
but i had to make a decision to get out
yeah
and then that was it that was it i was
in pakistan
and i made that decision i i
brainstormed
um my my riding partner who was a seal
his brother was a dev group guy that was
killed on a raid
trying to rescue a hostage in africa and
um
he is one of my best friends and i said
hey man i want to start a business
he's like what's brainstorm and we had
course of action development man we sat
down
after work and mapped out some plans and
and many conversations over dinner
trying to figure out like what i could
do
and um you know with our background
expertise
the obvious route is a tactical
something
right but i didn't want to do that man i
i i saw these dudes who are getting out
and they were dealing with all the
backlash of coming out and saying hey
i'm this guy because at the time i
didn't have any social media
and i'm like dude i don't i don't want
to be a tactical
kind of guy i want to do something kind
of different
and i wrote down survival and
you know primitive survival is what most
people think about when they think about
survival
but i said what if there's this niche in
developing like this modern survival
take on preparedness
of training citizens not just military
and law enforcement but
citizens to be better prepared in their
culture what year is this
this is 2015. damn so you were ahead of
the curve
yeah yeah this is 15. and i'm like
there's something here and i wrote a
mission statement i did a con op i wrote
a whole
five paragraph op order on the whole
business plan
and resigned from my position
with interagency came home talked to my
command sergeant major as a sergeant
major i was an op sergeant major at the
time
and said hey man i'm thinking about
doing this and he goes dude
like you haven't like there's nothing
going on it's like we're about to
activate the entire unit
and you'll be a staff sergeant major
sitting in a talk for a year in
afghanistan
there's nothing going on do what you
want to do
i said how hard is it for me to resign
he goes i'll i will type
the paperwork that's how easy it is and
then i'll just send it to you and you
sign it
for for your position and your rank you
don't have to do anything but
technically resign and you'll go into
irr status
inactive ready reserve and that's it and
i remember i did that
and the next day i was like holy crap
like i just cut the biggest umbilical
cord known to man in the history of man
and now i hear flapping and i have to
make it make [ __ ] happen
and are you still married at this point
i'm not i'm i'm
i'm three years removed or two years
removed from
a divorce and um
but you're not you don't have to take
care of anyone but yourself it's just me
yeah and so it's kind of like a little
bit of big umbilical cord but
i mean let's face it you're gonna be
able to
you know give me a ground pad yeah i'm
i'm i'm winging it man i'm
i'm i think i probably was living in on
a ground like a pad
like i i was probably an air mattress
inside of a abandoned place
i was smart with my money because they
call it the thousand air club
because you're making a thousand a day
and you're bankrolling
most guys go home blow it on harleys and
trucks
and come back and start the vicious
cycle again um
but i took that money i think it was 25k
and invested it and started my business
what was the first move the first move
was education
i had no idea educating yourself
educating myself
i i had no idea about marketing about um
like i have a degree in homeland
security what's that going to translate
to not much in
my new field of expertise so i took my
business plan
started doing um trying to build
fidelity on the correlation between
a concept and then the execution of that
concept trying to use historical data
and there was none
there was no good case studies or
examples of
businesses in that genre that weren't
very narrow in their field
perimeter survival yeah sure you could
find a hundred business plans they all
suck
and they're not doing very well but what
is this cultural thing of like this
genre of call preparedness
where mindset self-awareness uh
technical training
um you know all the things that we did
in our culture
and purpose in special operations how
does that translate to citizens and how
do you scale verticals in business
that that was intense for me it's
something i still learned today
you know five years later with 40 plus
employees i'm like
dude i'm still learning i'm trying to
figure the [ __ ] out what was the first
move that you made then
in terms of like what's the first gig
that you did so the first gig was
uh tactical training because i could
make a revenue stream
so i'm like wait do i figure out like 12
to 24 people
500 a slot pistol carbine let's make
some revenue
then i built the website then i started
marketing social media
for me was brand new and i think at the
time
was new for people to see special
operations guys doing it
i know at the time there was only a
handful of us doing that
and people were like oh and they
gravitated towards us i remember tim
kennedy i was his boss
tim kennedy was a is an mma fighter
um successful entrepreneur i was his
boss at the time and i'm like
dude how are you doing this he plugged
me on his social media i got 10 000
followers and i'm like
this is how it works this network
building that's how easy it was
and so i start building it i design a um
a survival kit i as a contractor
i went to um the luxury of doing the
interagency direct
contract position i can go to any
training i want to and they sent me to a
whole bunch of high-speed schools
including a survival school
where they had high-speed contractors
who developed this like
ziploc bag theory there's this guy right
now who works for me kevin estella
he's in the field right now day two
doing a 72 hour ziploc bag challenge on
fieldcraftsurvival on our instagram
and we're updating it and the idea is
if you're in a foreign country that's
semi-permissive non-permissive
the worst case scenario for you is it
loses its sovereignty
a coup happens and now you're on your
own the first star
in in the 50s that was applied to the
cia board
was a guy who escaped and evaded from
china
and got killed in tibet by a random
security guy
shot in the chest with one round with
like a 32 british pistol revolver
that's a thing and there's dangers of it
so the idea is like a ziploc bag
is the things that you can carry on your
person your physical body
so i took that and i literally in the
course went
everything you guys put in this bag how
did you guys come up with it well we did
r d like the best things that we could
put in the bag
and you're going to live out of it for
72 hours which happens to be
uh appropriate amount of time to escape
evade and then carry the appropriate
amount of stuffs in reconnaissance
like not overbearing and i said i'm
going to take everything in these bags
and i'm going to turn into a survival
kit and sell it and he's like dude you
should do that
like hell yeah i'm doing it and so i our
first survival kit
i sold like a thousand on day one of
that kit
and i was like there's something here
there's a product thing here there's a
training thing here
there's these revenue streams that i'm
seeing and we we built it from
very small diversified and and built up
all the verticals one one by one
so you sell a thousand of these survival
kits almost instantly
instantly so now so now your theory is
correct
there's demand there is demand i'm
creating a new demand
signal but there's demand um
that that starts off what year is that
six the very beginning of 16 the very
beginning of 16
so five years ago you get the word out
you sell a thousand these kits
and so well then what's the next move
now you know there's a market you start
developing [ __ ]
what's next well i think part of it was
i have to develop a culture here
like there's a there's this thing that
exists that i'm trying to redefine
um most people who think or have seen us
on the surface even
think that we're a primitive survival
company because survival is synonymous
with with primitive survival
like rubbing sticks together in the
woods and so
i'm not a big fan of that i'm not an
expert at that there's guys that are
talented at that i hire those guys now
but that's not me i'm the guy who
understands
that you know 20 operators can go out
and deliberately
hit the worst case scenario and come out
on top
and so in my hypothesis like why is that
happening
why do why do intentionally men
put themselves in harm's way to kill the
bad
guy and why statistically do they come
out on top
and so if you start looking out and
laying out all the reasons why
it's not because of one widget one
school
it's because the culture they're
immersed in it's they all got selected
together
they train together they pay attention
to all the details they can do
contingency-based planning
they have service support they do course
of action development they rehearse
they pay attention to their equipment
and everything they do and
ultimately they're conscious to their
culture their world they're they're here
right now paying attention to what they
are doing and when i look at citizens
and everything that's happening in our
world that we never learn the lesson
from
we're completely complacent in freedom
as a benefit of freedom
because we're comfortable and routine
and that happens to be
our mo as americans which is beneficial
right
that you live in sovereign societies you
get all the luxuries and freedoms of
all the men who go out to war and and do
this thing
but what is it to the detriment well
it's the if you look at statistics
and this is what i did this is this is
the greatest start point is doing this
research
i started realizing there's no
understanding of what this even means
there's one guy that i found there's a
couple guys but one guy significantly
by the name of john leach who did a
study on survival psychology
he asked the question why do people live
and why do people die
specifically in catastrophes he has this
theory
um based on this case study analysis of
mostly natural disasters some of them
man-made
that there's a breakdown of about 10 80
ten
ten percent of the population happens to
be making the right decision
and they survive eighty percent probably
broken in half fifty fifty
make sometimes the right decision
sometimes the wrong and then ten percent
are the bottom of the barrel
they're they're like the guy who runs
this is in a survival situation of some
kind this is a catastrophe a disaster
so all of the things coming together uh
typically uh associated with
um compressed timeline high intensity
stress
so the bottom 10 percent is the bottom
of the barrel
and children happen to be in that bottom
10 percent
and so the the the question is why
are some people at the top 10 and why
are people at the bottom 10
and how do we get the people who are at
the bottom even children into the top
ten
and that was the premise of my business
in answering that question
we need to figure out why people die
um what is their background and
experience
what mistakes they made and how can we
put them in a bracket
and a 10 bracket to make sure they
survive that that was the
the question that had to be answered
that's where that's where it started and
then you started looking at okay
what did you find what did you find as
far as a
curriculum that you put together that
moves people from the bottom ten
where getting killed to the top ten
the the most impactful thing that i've
found which i i see a lot of correlation
in what you're
with whether it's discovery or just
dissemination of your books and all the
information that you're doing
is self-awareness breeds
situational awareness right so there's
this lack of awareness
there's really a lack of understanding
uh the analogy i like to use
is um you know i have a land cruiser i'm
a big fan of land cruisers
so i i take my land cruiser which is a
94 land cruiser which is
um fcg80 if you're a land cruiser nerd
head gasket problems are notorious for
these things they overheat
their head gasket blows and then it's
catastrophic
so the question is when you're driving
down the road and you see smoke
how do you address smoke most people see
smoke and they go oh crap smoke let me
pull over
right i'll call aaa so they have a
dependence on something else an
institution
uh an insurance company whatever it may
be and so they don't source
sole source the solution another course
of action is you keep driving
because you don't understand what's
happening so you just push through
and you think that pushing through hey
because it's only 10 minutes away from
home
is the answer so you saw the smoke you
didn't have a
answer there's a void a darkness in the
back of your head
so you just do something random it's
randomized behavior
you drive you get home and before you
get home when you get down your street
your
car catastrophically uh implodes you
hear a pop
you hear noise it starts the the buck
you pull it over the side of the road
you lift the hood
and you realize you have a blown engine
right
that analogy is uh representative of
people's brains and the understanding of
the brain so
a lot of things that we have that happen
to us uh in our lives
um mostly affected by stressors which
happens to be a catastrophe by the way
a stressor is just either low-grade or
high-grade
catastrophe we take in stress we start
filling these things and then we don't
know how to control it we don't know how
to diagnose it
we don't understand mechanical processes
and then so we ignore it
until it becomes catastrophic so now
you're in the vehicle accident
and your only role is to do certain
technical things to help the person
who's burning alive
but you don't know how to do it why
because you don't understand
how to break glass you don't understand
uh the fortitude that's required to
push past the pain and break the glass
or maybe if you understood technically
that you could just crack off
this wire antenna and slap it that you
could shatter the glass
or if you even had more uh forethought
maybe you carry a tool like a breaching
ass a winkler
a breaching axe and you smash the window
but then you let that person burn to the
ground
hopefully it's not a family member
hopefully it's not you
but this happens and this little thing
happens to everybody in some kind of
circumstance
and what i tell people is if it hasn't
happened it's bound to happen
the difference between us and our
experiences and civilians
is that we've seen the detriment of not
following these basic processes
and the understanding of what takes
place is when you don't understand them
so what i want to do is lend these
processes and understanding so people
can self-diagnose
be aware of what's happening
sympathetically parasympathetically
and then give them more awareness so
when they see smoke
they go oh that's not smoke at all
that's water vapor
that's coming from our radiator oh i'm
gonna pull over i'm gonna let the car
idle and sit i'm gonna let it cool down
oh i carry gloves and
a rag in the back of my car i'm gonna
pop the radiator cap oh i realized
because i looked in the reservoir
there's nothing in the reservoir
i carry coolant because i have a 94 and
it eats coolant
i get coolant put it back in it top it
off sit it let it idle
everything seems fine and i'm on my way
and i just survived
that whole thing is not done in a very
tactful
and intelligible way and i think we need
to change that
so it requires processes it requires
progressive learning
it requires a different a lot of
different paths that haven't been
created
which is the which is the business
challenge because it's easy to
articulate it
to do a podcast to do a book all those
things
but to create a progressive path for
civilians who are disinterested in the
first place
it's the best in my opinion business
problem to have
because it lends itself to a new
challenge which i'm all about
so what do the courses look like how do
let's say you just sold me
and i'm like hell yeah i'm in the game
um freaking uh
jocko the whatever insurance salesman
and you just sold me what do i do
there's three progressive paths to this
the first path is phil crass arrival
fieldcraftsurvivo.com it's
it's it's the website it's physical
training it's like
physical things that you can do it's
gunfighter pistol gunfighter carbine
it's first aid uh tactical combat
casualty this is via a website
via website so you're for instance on
on on a video explaining to me how to
put a tourniquet
on my kid this component is you
physically come to our training
okay so there's a difference so you said
website but then you said physical
so you go on the website you get you
sign up for the training right
and then the the in-person physical
training is one component of it
that training includes equipment
augmentation and equipment look we're
not the
we don't own the monopoly on medical
gear but i'll i will sell you the best
medical gear that's made
north american rescue the same cats
seven tourniquets or cat tourniquets
that we used
we've seen them save lives so we sell
tourniquets survival kits
all the augmentation for enabling people
to be better prepared
that's phil craft survival the second
component
is progressive learning you have to be
able to learn
progressively at a start point and
understand the path
i realized that deficiency years into
this whole thing
because people go uh oh i train
gunfighter pistol what's next and i'm
like
uh get fighter pistol two and they're
like well
outside of that what's next like well i
need a
holistic path to this so we hired a girl
um her name's amber stay-at-home mom
uh nurse somebody who understands lms
systems we actually
teamed up with osmore which is a
learning management based system the
same thing we did with online learning
for your master's for my bachelor's
where we take um an online learning
approach
to get people involved including
families so
you can go online you could sell up you
could sign up on wetheprepared.com
and sign up for an lms component that
includes like
stop the bleed so you take a class where
you receive a tourniquet
you apply that tourniquet and you have
an interactive experience virtually it's
online learning
but it's for the preparedness minded
it's for people who
you know who don't have the time or
money to fly from north carolina to utah
to take a physical
class in person so there's a progressive
learning path
that touches all the fields that we
break down to what's called pillars of
preparedness which i can go over
of how we how we uh disseminate this
information
so people can understand it the last
component to that
is what i've realized uh that
preparedness is is it's this thing
that brings people together that's not
super toxic
like everybody can get if you're a
liberal in san francisco or conservative
in rural montana you can get on board
that
you need this idea of preparedness to
make you better prepared for the worst
case scenario
generally speaking so when i have
classes in person or online
i see this community building built
based off of this one thing
that's not segregating people or that
doesn't have toxic uh
underlying things about it right it's
not fringe so
we started uh american contingency which
is a communi
community-based program where if we
educate people to be better prepared
what's next what happens when you get
around people that
you like because you're you're thinking
about the same considerations like i
want to take care of my family
i want to protect myself um how can you
inter-operate
well there's look there's a there's a
bigger picture right the breakdown
of the family unit breakdown of uh
communities
when we me and you grew up we knew our
neighbors we knew our our neighbors
friends and family now if you see your
neighbor and he's checking his mail
you're like
you're like who's that guy like why is
he looking at me like that's your
neighbor man like what do you do
like for the first time in history you
could be in an apartment complex with
thousands of people in a vertical and
not know one person
and be disinterested in knowing anybody
but what do you do when you have to
band together because a hurricane just
destroyed the infrastructure of your
town
well american contingency we actually
have a members.americancontingency.com
that allows people to group and network
we have hundreds of groups
that are inter-operating now that are
like-minded that train together
that work together that build assets
and their capabilities together and then
to break bread together
which is building relationships so in
every tier
and this just happened which um you know
look i think the
the most impactful thing that you've
done
in your career in your in your life is
what you're showing
in um and what you do
and your actions outside of the military
right it's a it's somebody for me as a
young entrepreneur i look at you and go
these are the right things writing a
book in publication that is
that exposes your ideology and your
thinking
to impact young people who don't have
anything to lean on and purpose
is the most impactful thing that a human
being could do especially from our
backgrounds
so i said i'm going to do pillars of
preparedness teacher's thing
let me get a book deal nobody wants to
touch me
for years they thought i was fringe
i mean i've been called everything from
right-wing extremists which is bizarre
because i'm half asian
um to um you know neo-nazi to all this
weird stuff
because i'm i'm talking about this idea
of being prepared
um just two weeks ago i signed a book
deal with a major
uh publisher that vetted me for two
years which means they just paid
attention
about writing a book on preparedness and
i'm like
that's big that's huge for me one to be
able to impact some somebody via the
written word which i grew up with is
impactful
but two a publisher that published
michelle obama
and also jordan peterson on both sides
of the spectrum
is taking a chance on me and i'm allowed
i'm i'm humbled by the opportunity
allowed to have the opportunity to pass
this word
and mainstream to people who might be
thinking about this but don't know how
to contextualize it
is a sign to me that this is making
sense to people
like it's a hard genre because it's so
uh
it's spread so thin but the time and the
place that we live in our society right
now where
people's cell phones their virtual
realities are more important and
significant than their actual reality
at the detriment to their physical and
mental health and wellness
it it needs we need to be bringing this
to bear in conversations to get people
involved in something
outside of their cell phone so
it's my mission but it's become
something so different than i thought it
was going to become
as far as scaling a business vertical
let me tell you what i think this is
what i think is very cool and
and i was wondering if you would get
there
um just from what you've seen so far to
to what my perspective is and what my
perspective is
is you're sort of like what everything
you just said to me is
the tip of the iceberg actually it's
just the tip of the iceberg
and i'll tell you what i mean by that if
you look at for me
um jiu-jitsu jiu-jitsu for me
was a huge component of my life
not because i learned how to fight not
because i got in good physical condition
but because i learned a new way of
thinking and i started to understand the
world
from a different perspective and i
started to see correlations between
jiu jitsu combat tactics leadership
interacting with other human beings the
way i approached problems
the way i thought jiu-jitsu became a way
of thinking and it's actually
i can't say it's jujitsu is that way of
thinking because it's everything
combined
it turns and translates into this sort
of just the way of thinking for me
well when i start thinking about
being prepared about handling situations
about
about reacting to emergency situations
about handling contingencies all those
things
you can learn you can learn
for the specific for the specific genre
of actually applying to a survival
situation
just like you can learn an arm lock for
actually applying to
a grappling situation but guess what
you can take that mindset and you can
apply to everything that you do
so you can take what you're teaching
about
thinking through a problem about
foresight about
preparing for a certain scenario and the
contingencies around that
you can actually apply that not just to
how you're going to handle a fire or an
earthquake or a civil unrest but how are
you going to handle
a business situation that you're in how
you're going to handle an interaction
with
someone in your own family it's not a
hostile interaction but it's an
interaction that you need to think
through
so the way that you're talking about
preparedness
and i've told this to people before
they're like well you know how good do
you have to get at jiu jitsu
like i mean at a certain point you're a
blue belt you're 225 pounds jocko
um you're okay you can handle yourself
in a self-defense situation
yeah absolutely i can what about
shooting well
what are the chances jocko that you're
gonna get into
a gun fight you're 49 years old
you know you got a wife and kids you
live in a nice area what are the chances
you're getting in a gunfight why do you
need to be training
why do you need why should i be training
people ask me why should i work with a
firearm
well let me tell you why because yeah
you have this
narrow chance that for whatever reason
somebody enters your house or you're in
a situation somebody tries to steal your
car or
hurt you or whatever where you got to
use your firearm the chances of that
let's face it they're
they're they're tiny but guess what you
get
guess what you get from practicing and
art
like shooting you learn how to control
your breathing
you learn how to detach you learn how to
refocus after you throw a shot
and and still take the next clean shot
without worrying about what just
happened
you learn how to calm you you calm
yourself down
you learn how to associate or
disassociate from
problems that are happening right in
front of you so there's applications
to the art of shooting a weapon that you
can apply to everything you can do
there's applications for what you learn
in jiu jitsu that apply to everything
you do
there's applications to if i went to one
of your courses
and you taught me how to what what i
should put together for a go bag for a
car
here's what you should think through
cool i can promise you i'm gonna use
that i'm gonna put a go bag in my car
i'm gonna put together a good one but
guess what else i'm gonna do
i'm gonna think about a contingency for
my business and what we can do
as a business to prepare for a certain
contingency what do i need to prepare
what do i need to think through as a
leader
to to be ready so
you're talking about a narrow when you
talk about this mindset of preparedness
you're talking about a pretty narrow
thing how am i going to survive a
situation
to me it's applicable to everything that
a human being does
and and why does a special operations
guy
when there's a uh you know an earthquake
or a flood or a car accident
part of it part of the reason that they
survive is hey
they know what to do they know how to
break a windshield
they know what to do in that specific
technique they technically know what to
do
but part of it is number one they've
been under pressure before
and number two they know how to think
through the problem that they're facing
so what you're teaching isn't only
applicable to survival
it's actually applicable to everything
and that to me
is it should broaden your audience to
everybody and i like the fact that you
said you know there's a certain
alignment
with what you're doing the alignment is
you know we're one of those
with businesses sometimes if you go
higher up enough
the the alignment ladder
in a business you know you might want to
do something one way i want to do
something a different way
ultimately i say hey listen do we want
to take care of our clients
yes do we want to make some money yes we
do do we want to take care of the people
on our team yes we do
so we're going to be aligned there like
there's no one you're not going to if
you and i are in business together
you're going to say well actually i
don't want to make any money or actually
no i want to screw over our clients or
actually no i don't want to take care of
our team
no you're not going to say that and if
you did say that we're not working
together
but 99 of the time you go to any
business they you can go
to a point where you're aligned where
you and i are thinking the same hey
listen
we want to take care of our clients we
want to take care of our team
we want to make some money we can agree
with that what you just said
i don't care where you're from i don't
care where you're from
you take what did you say a a liberal in
san francisco
or a freaking redneck in montana and you
pull them into a room and say
do you want to be able to take care of
your family what are they going to say
they're going to say yes do you want to
be able to handle yourself in a pressure
situation they're going to say yes
do you want to be able to take care of
yourself they're going to say yes so
there's an alignment
that's that's inherent in what you're
teaching
that absolutely will bring people
together but it'll make them better not
just because they're able to survive
it'll it'll teach them a way of thinking
that will progress them
in every aspect of their life and that's
why i think it's
even more powerful than what you're
saying because i could take
some uh company executives and send them
to one of your courses
and and yes it's a cool benefit that
they're gonna learn
about survival just like i run a program
where we take our guy
we take civilians we teach them how to
do a room clearance we teach them how to
move between buildings right
this is a one this is a this is a 45
minute session right
how to clear a room and how to move from
building to building in a group that's
what we teach them
then we say okay here's your mission and
we start giving them missions now
what do they learn about clearing
buildings doesn't matter it doesn't
matter at all
but what do they learn about leadership
what do they learn about thinking under
pressure
what do they learn about how to get
people to move in the right direction
what do they learn about being able to
detach and take a step back
and not get caught up in the fire fight
we use we use labor attack not get
caught up in their laser gun and and
freaking out about that
so we take people and put them through
this tactical training
not so that they can become great
tacticians
but so that they can lead better so what
you're doing hey listen
it's great you put people through some
training that they learn survival skills
but to me an even even
higher up of the hierarchy of of
benefits
is that they learn a way of thinking
that's going to benefit them in every
aspect of their life
i think that's badass yeah yeah i
appreciate it the
the lessons learned that we found is
exactly that that
most often people aren't exposed
they they have limited exposure so when
they have the opportunity to do
something like
you know a five-day uh experience like
we have you know we do corporate
training we do um
we've done it i've consulted for oracle
and some other companies
it's not about like you said the
technical experience the bottom line is
they're not going to learn enough reps
to build that technical expertise
unless that's on their own but the life
lessons they learn
and taking it back and processing stress
like you said
is so important and valuable i think
what's happening with
this introduction of technology in our
lives
is it's limiting our ability to be
exposed
so um one of the advices that i give for
people
who are like how do i change my mindset
you know a lot of people say mindset
mindset mindset what the hell does that
mean in
in our field of expertise it has to do
with resilience
your ability to bounce back your ability
once suppressed to bounce back and to be
stronger
to thrive instead of just survive and
get by so
when we expose people to new challenges
it doesn't have to be extreme you could
just i mean we have extreme versions of
this we do seer school
we have a civilian school which is fun
to run but those guys
will come back from that experience from
a five-day seer experience survival
escape resist evade
and they'll go this is the most
impactful thing i've ever done in my
life
and i'm like really and like okay
let me reflect on my impactful
experiences oh yeah ranger school
when i was in ranger school and i'm
exposed and i'm
i'm vulnerable it's impactful because
it's something different and we
understand this obviously about even
single-celled organisms
if you're exposed to trauma that is the
first stage in growth
because no growth takes place without
exposure to trauma and so whatever that
form factor is
getting pummeled on the mats and jiu
jitsu you are
learning as you go you're breaking to
build and so
uh what's fascinating about this whole
movement that i that i think is
preparedness
is that it's positive there's not a lot
of negative
things that take place in preparing
people to be
prepared for that worst case scenario
you see a lot of positive impacts on
community with law enforcement
with relationships uh with people's
understanding
and for me um getting
getting all this collective of
information and making sense of it
and being able to clearly disseminate
that is the biggest challenge
but it's the funnest thing about the
business i mean the lms for example of
of creating this idea that you can learn
online
and you can learn about these
life-saving things the naysayers came
out and said
why would you teach somebody how to
apply a tourniquet online like
don't you think that's kind of like a
it's high in liability and it's
neglectful
i'm like dude you could build a a rocket
ship
inside of your garage off a youtube
video so i could think i think i could
teach somebody how to stop the bleed
with a technical
tourniquet applied to their body to help
them survive
and so i i'm fascinated by it's it's my
passion obviously but um
i think you're right i think especially
when it comes to leadership
uh there's a breakdown in our in our
societies with
guys not willing to get off the bench
and do anything for themselves
i was doing a podcast with pete blaber
he was a former
cad commander wrote the mission the man
and me
and work uh just wrote part two of that
which is the common sense way
and one of the things he talks about is
this idea of collaboration
when you collaborate with somebody when
you have communication
and you have reciprocation then you you
create the environment of
us willing to learn from each other but
you also give people the confidence to
stand up in their own communities and do
something about it
i don't care if it's not their community
like yeah you want to run for city
council that's great
you don't and you just want to stand up
and get off your ass for your family
or even for yourself you're fat you're
sloppy
you're lazy and you can make a change
inside yourself because you re
you come to that realization that's good
and for me
there's no revenue generated there it
could be a podcast it could be one-way
dissemination
that impact is priceless it's worth
everything in the world
so what are people going to do if they
want to get in the game with you
so they go to they go to
fieldcraftsurvival.com that's it i mean
phil cross survived look we're all over
the map on fieldcraft's survival we'll
get a podcast we've got the website
uh we could port you to
theweedtherepair.com which is the lms or
or members.americancontingency.com
um the start point is
start like in this experience listening
to the long-form versions
for free from youtube from podcast and
start developing an understanding of
what you want
and then you know it's it's it's all
over the map on like on instagram
uh phil craft survival my personals
mike.a.glover
but every day i'm living this one thing
i haven't detracted from
is consistency i might be making wrong
business decisions
i mean i might be jacked up in many ways
but one thing i could never be
criticized for is consistency
so i wake up every single day with this
on my mind and in the last six years
that i started this venture i don't
think i've had one day off
and that's okay because that my grind is
this purpose
and you know selfishly i don't know if
this is a tactic maybe it's done
um when we're unaware of it but i've
built a thing around me
that felt and feels like the team life
that i had the culture that i came from
and i i get the feeling in it in here
and then
in your gym and this in the people that
i i've met
and and in a similar experience i'm
doing the same thing on my end
in a parallel parallel but also
synergistic universe
is there any um mistakes that you made
from a business perspective that
were close to catastrophic have you
screwed up anything really bad or they
all just kind of little learn as you go
kind of learn as you go i think early on
i almost made a mistake
early on where i was told in the
diversification of all the things i was
doing was too much
and i get that if you if you looked at
me even today i mean
there's a lot of things we've got going
on but at the time
that all the verticals were spread so
thin
that nothing was gaining traction and so
i was told
find one vertical one thing one kit one
training session
and double down on that create one
little tiny
vertical scale that you can make revenue
from and then diversify
and i said no i can't do that i said
because this whole thing that's
preparing us is very diversified in the
first place
i can't teach mindset without teaching
physical training i can't teach physical
training
without an understanding of a mobility
platform
into your life so we have to do
everything at once and so
doing that was challenging because it
almost broke me i mean literally it
broke me like
i lived in my business uh with my
girlfriend for four months
and we literally lived in a warehouse
for four months
and showered it didn't have a shower it
had a pump shower that we camped with
that was our living circumstance but you
make those sacrifices in business
and then all of a sudden everything's
scaled at once and then you're like
oh okay so this is the place to be now
so
now it's about tactics and you know
developing the right
flow uh supply chain issues all these
things that everybody's dealing with in
business it's it's a it's a train wreck
but i wouldn't trade it for the world
and where are you based out of so right
now
we're in hebrew city utah uh
headquarters is there
we're standing up kevin owens a former
sniper teammate of mine who's
unilaterally running philcraft nc
he's standing that up and then raul
martinez my training director
has 20 subcontractors that teach all
over the u.s he's standing up in um
in arizona near phoenix north anthem
arizona which is north of phoenix
so we're standing up these small little
verticals
um evan hafer who's a buddy of mine owns
black rifle coffee
has given me the opportunity to sell in
a display about the size of this table
field craft survival swag and and gear
that we sell for equipment
um and that will be in every black rifle
coffee
it's in two right now being four next
week being hopefully in a thousand
when he's competing with starbucks um
but yeah we're all over the map man it's
freaking awesome
well hey man i think we've been going
for uh i don't know
we get four hours yet i don't know three
and a half something like that
um i don't wanna i don't wanna take up
too much more of your time and i know
you got a little
little uh plane to catch echo echo
charles you got anything
i do not thanks for coming good to meet
you nice meeting you too man
no questions from echo charles no not
today
we covered it all you you one podcast we
were talking about living off the land
yeah and um you know i was a
i was a radio man in my enlisted day so
i was always traveling light and
you know carry like no food just water
batteries in the radio and and then we
were talking about
whatever was uh like we were talking
about the civil war
and how those guys would just they would
live off the land right
and echo chimed in the fact that you
know he
had also he could also live off the land
not exactly so all right he was saying
you know if he's going to la for a
couple days
yeah he doesn't need to pack a lot yeah
cause worst case scenario live off the
land you
didn't bring a toothbrush brush cool
roll into walmart
yeah roll into a walgreens you get a
toothbrush wow that's what i'm talking
about bourbon survival that's
freaking surprising man i'm surprised
you didn't ask about like what the best
you know store was to get toothbrushes
at
cvs they're pretty consistent whatever
conceptually it was the same thing same
same instead of
packing a big bag or whatever like we
live off the
land yeah urban sprawl that's an urban
sprawl that's urban land
it's the same thing yeah yeah it's an
ecosystem let the environment provide
that's it right yeah there you go right
on it sounds good
mike any closing thoughts no i i just
want to uh just take a second and just
say thank you for the opportunity i
i will i will say just like i say on
a lot of podcasts with guys of your
caliber in your background
that you're doing something that i wish
a lot of guys with our background would
do
which is um get off the bench and and
take a stand and commit
to this burden of responsibility what
you're doing is growing a business but
what you're also doing is
impacting young people's lives and
every walk of life to do something with
their lives
that's purpose that's different than
anything else that
that's a structure and business plan
that this is an impact on culture
i think from you know as far back as we
could record
every major um battle that's been fought
those men came from war and affected
popular culture
whether it was cutting you know p51
mustangs making hot rods
chopping harleys um having an extreme
impact
there is a burden of responsibility of
men like you and me
that need to step up and accept that
reality the john plasterers the john
striker meyers of the world
are the ones who affected my life and me
stepping up and doing something about it
i'm not talking about just military
service i'm talking about
doing something impactful for your life
and this
the books the business that's the
vertical in revenue
that that's what scales the hierarchy um
and and grows but the impact it
transcends across society
and without you uh without your
abilities
to stay in it and stay committed we
wouldn't we wouldn't be affecting
popular culture like we are
uh and i think you're leading the way in
that way you know
i'm humbled to have been on this podcast
and to have the opportunity to speak to
your audience
uh but i just want to let you know that
personally um it's a big deal
and uh you're doing it you did it in
military service to me
we come from similar lines that's not
the greatest greatest impact
the greatest impact is what you're doing
right now so i appreciate it
well thanks i appreciate it i i'm not
sure i'm all that
you've uh made me out to be but but um
when i look at what you did in the past
and freaking just talking about your
deployments
i mean not not even there's not even any
words to describe
and and i know that you sit there and
think in the back of your head of like
you know guys that did 12 more
deployments
compared to your whatever five or six
and i think that's the feeling we all
have all the time and you even said it
today
there's you found out i found out
there's there's someone and not just
someone but there's a bunch of people
way better
than we are at that job and god bless
him for going out there and getting
after it
and and that being said what you did to
hold the line what you did to carry the
torch
appreciate it and then back at you once
again what you're doing right now
you know i think what you're doing right
now is going to have a huge impact and
is having a huge impact getting people's
mindsets straight
in a time when mindsets are all over the
map
seeing you do that that's impressive
and i hope you keep doing it brother
thanks brother will do
right on
and with that mike glover has left the
building
appreciate mike coming on um
freaking great story um
a lot of incredible stuff and what he
doing right now is awesome
talking about preparedness talking about
being ready
seems like we should start fundamentally
there's one area we can start to be
ready
sure today echo charles what do you
think there's always ways
to be ready be more ready
i think that self-evaluation part was
kind of critical
i mean it wasn't surprising like oh you
know like
but it was a good like kind of reminder
it's like that is like one of those
answers that lies like right be
below the surface that you already know
is there but it's not always revealed
self-reflect evaluate where are we you
know you would think that's obvious but
it's not it's not happening a lot of
people go through life without
evaluation
evaluating where they're at where they
could improve what they could do better
yeah
it's true and like i'd say this before
where it's in a way
depends on how you look at it it's a
good problem to have it means a lot of
our problems are solved you know if
you're not worried about this or that
happening
that just means that it's not happening
very often
you know kind of a thing which is a good
thing solved problems
tends to be a good thing tens do
okay anyway so we got to be careful
about that kind of stuff
we do want to keep ourselves ready
strong
healthy you won't have to exercise
strength every single day aside from in
the gym
see i'm saying like you
doing 20 rep squats right
like the results the reason you do that
that reason is not going to be
demonstrated displayed
put into play every single day in real
life you're not gonna
i guess maybe conceptually it might
but no it won't but there's a bigger
purpose here see i'm saying
it's just it's to stay ready
realistically
as ready as you possibly can and all
these different elements
so while we're on this path of readiness
capability health
mental and physical we might need some
supplementation
good good news is jocko has
called jackal fuel so let's start with
discipline
go rtd cans
it is the new it's the new era of energy
drinks
actual energy drinks yeah mike glover
said something real simple but real true
he's like i like it i like that it's
healthy
you don't have to worry about poisoning
yourself anymore
so i'm paraphrasing yeah that last part
but it's true though
and it you know i said before too well
yeah you sometimes i'm gonna drink two
of those
in a row sometimes three i did drink two
of them
just now yes in a row so you don't have
to there's no back-end price anymore
it's like oh wait i'm
actually technically i'm not physically
i'm not worried about becoming a type 2
diabetic
diabetic this afternoon correct i didn't
just drink 72 grams of sugar or whatever
no no i had monk monk fruit which is
technically good for you
yeah that was a good point you made this
off air by the way
where you're like yeah you know there's
five calories and some the new ones this
15 calories because it comes from food
that's right yeah
the sweetener comes from food not some
chemical
that shouldn't be in your body yeah they
can't provide any kind of calories
between five and 10 calories per can why
is that
like you just said because it's not
chemicals you know what has zero calorie
calories a chemical that's what has zero
calories
what has some calories monk fruit has
some calories yeah
five yeah so it's one of those deals man
like i said the new era of energy drinks
you can drink some energy drinks there's
your energy drink right there on the
path hundred percent too
it's not like it's like well you know
i'm putting something in there to
preserve it partially
it's not partial path 100 on the path
100 no deviation
so yes you can get these there's new
flavors up by the way
you're gonna have to check them out
yourself very
impactful exciting flavors as far as
flavors go
anyway you can get them at wawa if
you're in the area that you have wawa
you can get them at uh vitamin chop
by the way talking about flavors uh what
i find interesting is
some families of beverages they kind of
all taste the same
they might have a different label on it
or a different name
this stuff tastes legitimately different
like you might have one and be like this
is the best thing i've ever tasted you
might have another one not like it
try a different one yeah because there's
definitely
more variation in flavor with these
flavors than there is
with a normal uh company a normal drink
who's just like look they know what the
flavor profile is to get people addicted
so they put a bunch of sugar in there
name it something
and cool they're moving forward we're
not doing that we're giving you legit
flavor profiles
with different tastes it's a good point
keep your mind open
also you can get them at originusa.com
also as far as supplementation goes we
have stuff for your joints
super krill oils and joint warfare also
for immunity
vitamin d3 and cold war
also if you need additional protein if
you want additional protein
or if you want dessert and
or
total win and it's not like i was like
let me just choose the p i just grabbed
any one and it happened to be that yeah
so i'm like cool i i went kind of hard
though i don't recommend this
all the time i put some chocolate chips
in there on accident put too many
not that not way too many but too many
and then
kind bananas disqualifies everything
you're saying a little bit huh you can't
just
add chocolate chips and be like oh it
tasted really good you added chocolate
chips bro
but it was like almost
too sweet i think because of the
additional chocolate chips
yeah i pondered the whole thing don't
get it wrong it was still very very
good you know what you do you you know
those uh the dark chocolate
chunks you can buy dark chocolate you
know
whatever percentage put that in there
that would have been perfect even if i
accidentally put too much
that won't shake anyway there's other
flavors as well
so don't you know don't slack on that
either way whatever flavor you like
milk additional protein another clean
deal
it's not like some sugar-filled deal it
is once you put freaking chocolate chips
in it
you know it's going to depend on the
level of
dark chocolate roberts with the freaking
sugar cubes under your tongue it was
just one of those things you know it
happened something but
i don't put chocolate chips in there it
tastes freaking delicious yeah totally
does
so there you go get some milk get some
get what you need yep chocofuel.com and
and by the way this is
important
it's important oh just this is important
i think i'm gonna say something that is
the thing that's important is
if you want to get you if you want to
get free shipping
get a subscription if you subscribe you
um we know we're competing with some
large
maybe even the largest of organizations
in the world that are shipping stuff for
free
no big deal we're shipping for free too
subscribe
we got you yeah it's true um also i
mentioned originusa.com
this is where you can get american-made
denim
american-made jiu-jitsu ghees rash
guards so
basically apparel for work a pair for
jiu jitsu
and then everywhere in between basically
forever for the whole life increased jiu
jitsu yep 100
origin usa.com again all made in america
from the ingredients
or materials not ingredients
the materials all the way to the end
product boom all made in america so
you're supporting yourself
are you supporting america as well
also chocolate win win-win big time big
time
also jock has a store called jocko store
so you go to jackalstore.com
and this is where you can get rashcards
t-shirts
trucker hats flex fit hats hoodies all
this
good cool stuff representing the path
discipline equals freedom
good when things are going bad
there's always some good that comes from
it
iconic video words from a man right here
nonetheless
you want to represent that that's where
you can get the shirts on jacko's store
so is this the video that's iconic or is
it the words
i don't know i didn't evaluate it kind
of seems like both i guess
technically but you're saying you made
an iconic video is what i'm hearing
either way good job either way we have a
subscription situation as well for
shirts
design's a little bit different than
iconic designs well
you know it's that's the subject for
debate
i think but people do seem to like them
you know you wanted a
cool new shirt every month high quality
by the way boom you can subscribe for
that
uh to that it's called the shirt locker
you can get it on jocko store
also subscribe to this podcast if you
haven't already
leave a review if you're in the mood
that's kind of cool yeah that's
that's that's cool also we have jocko
unraveling which i do with my
my brother daryl cooper dc
grounded podcast warrior kid podcast you
can also join the underground jocko
underground.com
we have alternative podcasts we're going
into some pretty cool subjects on there
look we made that in the event that
there's problems
in the in the podcast realm and people
start trying to
block or erase or
put inject advertis all this stuff that
they could do
if that gets out of hand which it could
we will
make adjustments and we'll be on
jockowunderground.com if you want to
support
that you can sign up you can subscribe
to eight dollars and eighteen cents a
month and you can listen to
all these alternative additional
podcasts that we're making
and we're gonna do other cool stuff that
we haven't really even um
started yet but we got cool ideas
that will come out we have a youtube
channel subscribe to that
if you want to see the videos that i am
the assistant director of
and the videos that sometimes i i am um
in them which is kind of cool that i do
role
i both the assistant direct and i and
you're the talent yeah
both talent either way yeah but it is
true we do have a youtube channel
video does it make you mad when you're
when you're um
directing a video and then i give a
little suggestion and it
kind of makes a big difference because
you always seem a little bit frustrated
no no no no no
you always seem like a little bit
frustrated you kind of
you kind of the good thing i'll say
you're humble enough to be like you do
the shot
whatever the adjustment is but then
i feel like it it i feel like you have a
hard i think those nights you don't
sleep as good as you do
if you come in and you got the shots
well a wise man once told me
and when i say once i mean plenty of
times that
as a leader i need to always my goal
should be to do your team member's idea
not your own idea so from a leadership
perspective you do a good job
yeah of going like yeah okay good that
sounds like a good shot we'll do that
shot i like it a lot
that's good even if it's an eighty
percent solution even if it's
what i'm asking you so from a leadership
from giving you a you know an a
minus you know yeah but what i'm saying
is
when you go home at night and the little
demons start to knock at the door and
you wonder
you wonder why the assistant director
had to come up with that shot
yeah i had this had to say hey let me
give you a little
little help sir look
like what it makes me happy
that you know we were able we were able
to collectively come up with a viable
idea
you want to know why you got the a minus
what because i can see it in your face
i can see in your face i can see the
frustration when you don't come up with
the shot
when it's when it's when you have to
take advice from the a.d
when you have to take advice from the ad
you know that's when i realized
a little frustrated i can see it in your
in your face i can see it in your eyes i
can kind of feel it too yeah well
i'll give you credit it's still an a
yeah because you still do your best to
get the good shot
i haven't had you sabotage a shot yet
and said yeah you know it actually
doesn't work
but i can see that it's frustrating yeah
well you keep talking
talking to me with that in condescending
tone i'm about to go
c plus on you pretty soon
either way anyway
psychological warfare if you know what
that is an album with tracks
jocko talking to you through your ears
about why and how to get past moments of
weakness
even if he imposed those weaknesses on
you himself
as the case may or may not be sometimes
okay check
hey dakota meyer's got a company called
flipsidecanvas flipsidecampus.com you
can
get cool stuff to hang on your wall i
got a bunch of books
i got a new book coming out it's called
final spin it's
a we're not sure what to call it
it does tell a story parts of it are not
written normal
it's a strange story there's some
interesting characters in there
some literature or something maybe
literature
maybe poetry maybe a transcript we're
not sure what it's called
it's a new form of writing
if you want to check it out it's called
final spin
pre-order it so that the publisher knows
to print a bunch of copies
leadership strategy and tactics field
manual the code the evaluation the
protocol display equals freedom field
manual weigh the warrior kid
one two and three and four
then we have mikey and the dragons we
got about faced by hackworth we got
extreme ownership and the dichotomy
leadership
that i wrote with my brother leif babin
who i also have a leadership consulting
problem if
uh a leadership consulting company
where we solve problems through
leadership go to echelonfront.com
for details on that we have extreme
ownership academy extremeownership.com
where we have
virtual learning and live virtual
learning
leadership is not an inoculation you get
a shot now you know it no you got to go
to the gym every day the leadership gym
come and get it next live event
is the muster in phoenix august 17th and
18th
and then las vegas october 28th and 29th
we've sold all these out go to
extremeownership.com
click on events get registered and
if you want to help service members
active and retired you want to help
their families you want to help gold
star families check out
mark lee's mom mama lee she's got a
charity organization and if you want to
donate or you want to get involved
go to america's mightywarriors.org and
if you want
if you want more of my colorless
chroniclings
[Music]
or you need more of echo's inane
interjections
you can find us on the interwebs
on twitter on instagram on facebook
echoes adequate charles i am at
jacqueline
mike glover mike glover's
on twitter mike a glover1 on instagram
mike.a.glover and then of course he's
got
field craft survival and
fieldcraftsurvival.com
check his stuff out lots of great
information
and um well
thanks to mike once again for for coming
on for sharing
your experiences and knowledge mike it's
awesome even more thanks for your
service
for taking the fight to the enemy which
you most certainly did worldwide
freaking outstanding thank you and to
all
our military personnel that are right
now out there taking the fight to the
enemy
thank you for what you're doing every
day to preserve our way of life and the
same goes to our
police and law enforcement firefighters
paramedics emts dispatchers correctional
officers border patrol
secret service and all first responders
thank you for preserving our safety here
at home
and everyone else out there let me ask
you a question
are you ready are you ready for
contingencies are you ready to maneuver
if you have to
are you ready to save your friends your
family yourself
are you ready
well you should be we all should be
so get your mic glover on
train plan prepare
by going out there every day and getting
after it
and until next time this is echo and
jocko
out